two
January 25th
a holy day a blessed day why because the
H3 podcast is live yet again
it's Wednesday baby
and uh we're here to put on another
great show thank you for being here and
thank you to our sponsor Shady rays
cheers to that
hope you guys like my new mug
hmm
I can't imagine what it says under that
green tape that we got there
your cousin made that Ian
no yes yes my cousin Allison she loves
the podcast oh I love her shout out to
Alice
[Applause]
say let's get restarted that's awesome I
know well shout out thank you for this
and I fully stand behind the message of
it of course it brings it speaks to my
soul
um by the way you guys might notice that
my face is looking kind of greasy today
I don't know man I don't it's like as if
I needed more problems
all of a sudden like I'd say three
months ago I started getting like what I
think is eczema only on my face nowhere
else in my body just on my face dude get
your balls off my face man
and it shows up here and here and here
and here
and no matter what I do I'm I'm gonna
see a dermatologist soon but
no it's not it's always there bro always
and so I'm in this forever cycle of
putting on like cortisone is that what
it's called with the yeah a little
steroids in it I put that on it goes
away in two days and then it comes back
only in my [__] face bro can you put
on like my back or some [__]
you're a lying dog face Pony no
I'm sure if you go to a dermatologist
they'll totally give you a cream that'll
fix it yeah well I'm going soon
hopefully
oh brother does that happen when you're
like 37 and then one day you just start
getting eczema on your face no no uh
that's not a 37 thing that's a that's a
42 thing
a serious medical question Dan
[Music]
um
I mean generally yeah we're getting old
we're falling apart man you got eczema
as you get older I thought it was just
like you have it or you don't I get I
don't know about Eczema but I get
you can get eczema I'm not a doctor I'm
a [__] [__] it does happen in older
people due to uh psychological aging
issues no not a cycle sorry I read that
wrong physiological age that's like
psychological yeah
oh so my body's just [__] getting old
as [__] and you're getting red in the
face literally old man couldn't it be
somewhere else though
at least it's not psychological
[Music]
I can't get out you need to go home and
think about being young
37. really
We Are Young we are older
well um by the way all right thank you
cut the sad music it's not actually look
pretty good in black and white because
you can't see it I mean that again maybe
do the whole show like this huh
not everyone's young and healthy all
right I'm fine it's just a little eczema
God damn I'm not dying
thank you
so my face is a little shiny today damn
Dan blessed me with a great compliment
for the show he says I'm like a Tim and
Eric character
yeah you remind me of uh Casey and his
brother
and I just got [__] Vaseline
slathered all over his face
this is who Dan says I look like okay
just to show you guys what I'm dealing
with here right before the show starts
it's not your fault okay
here this is what Dan says I'm looking
like
bro that's not what I'm trying to hear
before I go live
there's another one I need some
confidence boosting Vera what the [__]
is this [__] Dan
[Laughter]
yeah thanks Joe best crew in the game
shout out Joe W Dan
um
yeah so I was planning I had this big
plan to hang out with Aiden Ross
yesterday
of course
um
it didn't happen and the reason it
didn't happen is because he never went
live and I think he was dodging me
it's just a fact like where is he is he
live today you know like where were you
Aiden
also I tried reaching out to him through
Hassan
I Tried dming Him
I tweeted at him
so he's dodging me [__] you
after he sent me his address
invited me
damn right I don't give a [__] I got the
Morpheus glasses and everything look at
this [__] bro
I'm like Bizarro Morpheus
bro I even got a leather trench coat the
pink dress shirt green he I just
realized he dressed a lot like Joker
but the pink and green tie right purple
you know purple suit
so you [__] me dude
and now that your punishment is you have
to sleep in the Matrix forever nobody's
coming to save you now
[__] in that [__] sludge pod baby
we're gonna turn your ass in a battery
loser a little hairless twink in a
sludge pod it's just a fact in my
opinion you know what bro when you're
ready to exit when you're ready to wake
up you reach out to me I'll be waiting
sucker [__] you sheep bot that's what
they say manuscript
MPC your NPC bro you're a bot
well blindly following some insane Alpha
Dogma
[Music]
so any anyway I wasn't able to do it
unfortunately I do wonder if he was
dodging me though I'm just gonna be real
about it
I mean he's a busy guy he might [__] a
busy guy that's his job
does he stream every day
I know I don't from what I understand I
have a confession I don't I don't follow
Aiden on Twitch he's a busy guy it's
[__] it's a Tuesday in the middle of
the day go to work when I look at this
analytics before the band he was
streaming every day so interesting well
then maybe he is dodging you
yeah by the way here's Aiden I was
scared actually after I saw this I
thought maybe it was a bad idea to show
up
and those are power punches his
shoulders
so I
is this a joke hey hold on hold on is
this a joke it might be I mean you never
know with him what's what's serious and
what's not I don't think it's a joke I
don't know and Wally's you know openly
says I was the worst student he ever had
starting out but I don't even think I
was this bad here's the thing
I get not being the best at first but
don't post this
you know what I mean also the only
reason it's making a sound is because
this dude's slapping his hand as hard as
he can way more powerful yeah
dude he stands up like big Ed this is
how you fight
he's practicing is nothing holy [__]
that's that big head style yeah wait
this is how you punch in a dream look at
this
it's underwater yeah
I love you Aiden
hey I can't punch you know what I mean
you like mayonnaise but if I record that
I sure as hell wouldn't post it no I
don't like Manny why do you keep asking
you like mayonnaise
what are you talking about why do you
keep asking me that
who even is that it's big head bro
Manny's I didn't recognize his voice
you like mayonnaise you like mayonnaise
I feel like we discovered Big Ed and I
just want to remind everybody that we
had big Ed in our studio years ago to
put mayonnaise and Zach's face before he
was on any other show he didn't even
have a thousand followers
and we had him on well I'm just saying
he's one of the most hated people
so far I feel you should get the apology
Podium for that apparently uh do you
still watch the 90-day show at all bro
I used to love that show
I have a trouble I have trouble with it
now Allison
watches everything
um she is still fully on board because
there's like 50 spin-offs now it's like
insane yeah and um she tells me that the
the 90-day Community has long since
turned on Ed and there's like like they
want they want him off the show like oh
I know that like they advise him
legitimately everybody has hated him
since he came on and rightfully so the
man is just a [__] Gremlin I mean
he's so the way he treats treated the
girl he was with in his Original season
was like so gross dude oh he's gotten
like engaged and then they called the
engagement off and it's flip-flopped so
many times with him
yeah he's doing good though or you know
what he's doing good well what he is
he's getting paid when he came on our
show he had a day job yeah true yeah he
was a photographer I think you know yeah
because that's how we got a hold of him
yeah we like reached out to his business
yeah we called called him that's
sometimes what you got to do when you're
Scrappy yeah
it was awesome though yes so um
why are we talking about Big Ed because
Aiden was fighting like him in that
video
I I can't see through these very good
because all the [__] vaseline on my
face got on the lens [__]
um oh I want to say a little show note
um okay
here's to all the industrial
entrepreneuring Spirits out there
I am opening our IP
to the world
this is a message with peace and love
you can now make your own H3 podcast
that's right everyone
I guess
that's not what I mean that's not what I
mean you can't make a fake H3 podcast
although you probably could actually
because I don't think anyone would
mistake it I mean if it's a parody you
can do whatever you want anyone would
mistake it so our my oh our IP is open I
got inspired by Hassan
he has that the Assan industrial complex
so I want the Ethan industrial complex I
think it's a good idea I like it
um yeah I think it's really cool
and it's actually crazy how like many
people are seemingly making a decent
living from having their own Clips
channels of him
so if you want to cut up
clips from the podcast
from our members live from anything with
me in it
go for it man monetize it I will not
claim I will not remove I will not do
anything I mean to be fair it's it's
basically been my policy I don't claim
or remove anything really at all and now
you're making it explicit yeah
the only time I'll remove something is
like if it's just a wholesale
re-uploading of like an episode and we
used to have that big problem we were on
Twitch if you're up if you're
re-uploading just full vods then that
that you cannot do
you if you're you're cutting highlights
yes if you're just re-uploading a video
that's stupid
obviously
yeah
yeah so uh get out there
and start earning people here's the clip
go look for the clip there's money out
there are you gonna grab it or are you
gonna sleep on it for the clip
the clip clip clip clip clip
Bella Simmons another 50 Bella where is
this money coming from
you know
but thank you so much
um
Webkinz international trading says I
don't know if Ethan will still see this
but I'm dealing with the same thing try
eggplant um
eggplant seeds I heard can cure any skin
ailment
thank you we'll try that
last night and
no eczema
I'm saying
[__] all I'm saying the proof is there
uh senem said cortisone cream only makes
it worse look up cortisone withdrawal
that seems a little
um
alarmist
right
uh I am no dermatologist but chromosome
is kind of a serious thing like you said
it's there's like a steroid wait hold on
maybe I'm not it's it's a
over-the-counter thing is it
hydrocortisone yeah yeah or no it's not
a cream it's like Vaseline is that what
it am I saying it right if it's just
it's not that serious if it's just
petroleum jelly then that's not that's
true no steroids it's just this
what is it it's just over-the-counter
[__] oh yeah no I mean that's that's
serious I used to get like like a rash
like that but on my neck and there were
times that I would put cortisone cream
on and it would make it itchier
oh really no it doesn't make me itchy I
don't think they're always instructed to
put it
yeah I don't think they're I think
they're saying over a long term like you
said you've been using it I used it like
once or twice a week oh that doesn't
seem too bad but and I just applied it
and basically in the evening before bed
but obviously there's got to be a better
solution because this isn't working at
all
um oh love's not losing his job you guys
it's pretty funny it's dude the thing is
like it won't even affect what we do
what love does love has so much work you
guys don't even know
yeah and frankly people have like you
said I mean people have been doing this
there's quite a few podcast clip
channels out there as there is all
that's changing is that you're allowing
them to monetize it right
well I don't know that there's like
because Hassan's main Channel he posts
clips and then and people watch those
and then there's like you know three or
four big channels that just cut their
own [__] and upload it and people watch
those too yeah he's got a lot more I
don't think he's made it explicit you're
right yeah I don't think I don't think
that there's going to be a negative
outcome you know what I mean from that I
think it's all yeah not talking good I'm
talking I guess less highlights and more
like like for example there's a channel
that I love and Shout out if you're
watching right now that does the best of
Zach's sound bites each month shout out
yeah that's that's awesome yeah and all
they do is find all of the really funny
sound drops that Zach did over the
course of like the previous month
compile it and post it and I I see those
pop up in my feed and I always watch it
it always cracks me up yeah those one he
put a lot of effort in those would be
fair use in my opinion yeah sure but but
you'd yeah that even beyond that you can
just cut funny stuff and put it up
whatever you want to do man just don't
do a whole [__] three hour episode
code I always see the Zack one and then
not Olivia H3 I don't know if you guys
get that everywhere I haven't seen not
Olivia what's that one it's just all
like it's all Olivia clips
it's just yeah oh wait yeah I think
there's one of those for me called Dan
the hater I've seen that somebody sent
it of it a clip for me
I think some people think that the not
Olivia H3 is actually me because it's
called not Olivia but I swear on
everything I believe in it's not me I'm
not uploading clips of myself hello
Olivia Hello Olivia look at this 2 000
subscribers Dan the hater yes I think
the Zach one has a pretty big sub count
I think I'm maybe subbed to the Zach one
from Zach's best shout out to that
person because that takes a lot of work
so I respect it
wow well guys get out there and spread
your wings
it's your moment
um this person's asked Pharisee said
what about re-uploads of full vods when
we remove them what does that mean like
when we have to delete an episode oh
yeah no that totally if the episode is
erased by YouTube go for it you know
what I mean I like that it's up
not if it's erased because well
something horrible happened that we well
I can't control it no matter what I mean
that's true like every episode that's
been taken down because what something I
said and we got a strike somebody else
re-upload it and YouTube doesn't do a
[__] about it it's kind of funny yeah
yeah if it gets taken down go for it
somebody said voice critical said his
non-affiliated clip channels are
claiming each other though
well yeah obviously don't [__] do
that that's [__] yeah because you
don't own the content so if you start
claiming [__] that's really stupid
that's dumb I see Chad asking about
members content like see you next
Tuesday yeah behind the scenes yeah you
can clip that
paywall [__] you can clip it go for it
this is kind of my my dream when I
started out doing Adriana context this
is like literally my dream because I was
scared to use Clips at first like I was
I was worried about you guys getting mad
I actually did a whole website with like
clips and [__] oh [__] yeah I hired the
right man
yeah wow
love are you about to start Moonlighting
doing your day job just the same same
highlights but on a different Channel Oh
yeah double dip that's true
I'll just flip them or something Ferris
says their name is Ferris thank you for
the correction
all right you know what I gotta change
shirts this caught the color on this is
all can someone grab me one of the new
shirts off the rack this is bothering me
I hate when shirt colors get all
stretched out like that
you know what I mean I mean it doesn't
help them I mean people like seeing a
little bit of that chest here you know
gotta
gotta work with what you got you know
what I'm saying I'm saying dog
works for a song
sun's out the sun's out
and [__] [__]
runs out everybody
that's great
breasts reached your eyes brass breasts
I didn't realize I had such small
nipples
[Music]
Mall yeah they are kind of small they're
small they're kind of small I guess
they're a little on the small plan I
don't think they were always small I
think as I got fatter they stayed the
same size
[Music]
um
thank you oh I'm at the beach perfect
now it's totally appropriate
all right today we have a really fun
segment breaks Guinness world records
every day this man is Unstoppable his
name is Rocco Mercutio
Mercurio
I'm not sure that all these are Guinness
World Records uh
and I'm not sure that all of them are
cool but it is it is there it does exist
check this out here I'll just I'll open
his most recent one
so this is
scooping what looks like cottage cheese
into from One Bowl to another and Nobody
Does it as fast as him nobody
look at that oh this is a long one yeah
he's got good form his whole body moves
with the spoon that's what you want to
be doing yeah yeah also he's using the
smallest spoon in his kitchen of course
is that oatmeal or cottage cheese yeah
maybe oatmeal pudding or something
because it's steaming so it must be
oatmeal oh [__] oh no no oh well you
guys you guys kind of get the idea on
that one yes yes yes these are tomatoes
in a jar oh he's fast though look at
that this is his specialty
putting stuffing scooping yeah
so this guy
yeah congrats bro you definitely crushed
that
I think what's funny is if you do
something obscure enough you're gonna
have the world record like I'm sure that
there isn't
someone scooping
candy Tomatoes into a tiny Tupperware is
that hasn't been recorded yet but it has
now
it's like a kid making up their own
rules as they play the game right yes
yes so
um
here's another one
okay
um okay this one is actually going for
something
this one he's actually doing something
let me look for one here this one is two
million some of them blow up some of
them don't
one hand behind the back like a true Pro
what is he gonna do
let's see what you got buddy
oh he's doing it already yeah he's
moving very slowly
so this this is the world record on
pulling poker chips holding three
champagne glasses pulled by a roll of
toilet paper
and again
I don't think anyone's ever attempted
that record and that's what we love
about it it's pretty hard because the
the Plies can like
um like grip absolutely so many points
of failure yeah so many points of
failure here
holy moly
I can't tell if this guy's serious or if
he knows that it's like silly oh it's
serious it's very good yeah I think he I
think it is serious
he doesn't appear to have a job because
he's post these every day in the middle
of the day
huh but who needs a job when you're
breaking our world records
oh
yeah that one was actually impressive
okay you think that's a fake conspiracy
that was my first thought let's see how
they fall in the last one pay attention
to the last one yeah it came from the
right yeah oh yeah yeah yeah his went
all the way over here his went this way
watch this
[Music]
watch where it goes
yeah dude it went like this
from the right
yeah it literally came from unless this
is the magic candy
right Dan are you still doubting that's
wrong go frame by frame use the little
yeah I will look how it comes in oh wait
oh he turns around
see that what's that angle yeah okay
okay it's a little questionable also I
know he has like a wife or girlfriend
who helps him on these videos
[Music]
co-conspirator
I bet if you analyze this video super
closely you can even see the reflection
of the person throwing it oh good point
look well let's take it if you're really
trying look at that light in the right
side yeah yeah I actually don't
one of the comments on the side it says
you can hear them land somewhere else
too
yeah this one's a little sus well that
puts it all into [__] question then
doesn't it I think I think he's very
competitive and he doesn't want to lose
to the other guy with the bubble gums
and the little milk glass behind the
back
that's heartbreaking that's the skill
though popcorn in the mouth oh you know
what I feel like I could have beat him
at this one I'm good at this
you got it brother
now I'm wondering if this one is fake
too
how's this one fake I don't know you
just quiet
so what we've done is each of us has
found a video of his that we believe we
can compete in
and we are putting a challenge
to his world records and we are calling
him out we are putting him on notice
Rocco
Mercurial he's Italian
[Music]
it's come to my attention that some of
your records may not be totally legit
and well I understand the competitive
spirit I cannot accept this
it was on my heart you broke my heart I
thought you were the Guinness World
Record Man and now I find you're nothing
more than a common fraud I know it was
you afraid of
we are gonna try to beat your records
today
what if we were to lose who's to say it
was in fact
[Music]
uh Rocco
Rocco
but I'll go
all right thanks
so let's see
um
just to get you guys hyped I wanted to
explain that here here's one with 1.6
million
yeah a sponge okay now this is one that
we're doing
this is a really weird
um record
just because oh he's trying to fill it
up I see I see it yeah transfer the
water with the sponge uh yeah I believe
uh Lena uh is set to break this record
that's what I'm going to be going for I
think you can beat that yeah me too it
was between this and the popcorn one but
the popcorn one although I practiced it
seemed easy but I feel like I'll get
nervous on camera and mess it all up
you're good at the throwing [__] in your
mouth and catching it yeah yeah I'm
pretty good at that too yeah but I
thought so yes yes intra office
competition you know I mine was a squirk
on one and the squirkin we have sucks
dude so I'm not feeling confident at all
in fact I want to change my challenge
well what do we have a some popcorn or
maybe next door in their snack popcorn
bag because you could maybe last minute
just do the popcorn thing
let me uh let me go poke her in I I yeah
that would be more exciting because the
squirt gun unfortunately just sucks yeah
the the the the the beam uh it's not
tight enough it doesn't hit with enough
Force Sam is is gonna be competing are
you doing the Ritz one Sam or the price
okay the Sam was thinking about doing
the Ritz one
and here you go this is the first or
fastest I don't know about first the
fastest man to stack 35 Ritz with
chopsticks mini Ritz of course the big
Ritz is a different record
of course it's all completely different
technique yeah
so
there's something going on in the
background someone's like watching Civil
War or something
I love this guy he's
um
I love this guy's dedication to this
it's kind of everything to me
the background noise
yeah but is he in a restaurant it sounds
like an industrial
kitchen no I think his wife is just
cooking that's how unimpressed she is by
this [__]
he's doing it all the time Rocco's doing
his records again
actually
this is impressive this it's not easy
second 35 mini Ritz like that
yeah
so we've got everybody's going to be
competing today Lena's grabbing a day of
skinny pop downstairs okay awesome
look how many videos he has though just
the breath of work
is just incredible he's great at what
he's here's the what's fun interesting
he has actual official certificates on
this [__]
he's a winner
okay here actually it says oh [__]
I can't zoom on it or we'll go to the
next one
the fat
oh wait I was I wanna
thank you okay
this one says the most cups
lubricated
what is it oh
on the forehead
and 1.79 seconds
bro do they just do you just pay them
and they print this out for you he's
probably just has a template doing it
himself this is the other ones is the
fastest the the fastest time
to flip three water bottles in 1.28
seconds achieved by his name and then at
the date he just made these yeah yeah
you're right
okay
or is this the stand is this the
standing record he's attempting a break
okay he's got the certificate that's
gotta be his
no way he's going to put that all in his
head
this is a world record
this is a Guinness World Record
I you got to tell you I mean that that
ain't easy right some of these are
impressive that's what's so weird about
it some of them are impressive and some
are like
so silly what is that well yeah that's
the thing when we are practicing and it
actually came down to the logistics of
doing these things yes he's better than
a lot of us oh yeah no he's so good he's
really good at weird
super weird yes
not even real tricks basically fake
tricks I shouldn't say that though I
shouldn't joke about him like that yeah
well I've got a lot of other stuff but
maybe we should just get into it I've
already set it up uh well we have to do
our ad break we're at 31 RCS Farsi thank
you for the fit gifty subbies we love
you
yeah this guy's the new dirt Dude
Perfect watch out another 50. these
people doing blocks of 50 man
impressive from after Farsi there was
another 50. no well earlier uh uh Bella
did 50. yeah I know they're insane
but you shared the gift of membership
Glock comes with that these days
members Feast these days
all right let's thank our sponsor and
then we'll get into the challenges
and y'all are going to be shocked and
mesmerized by what you're about to see
yes Shady Rays thank you we love you
Shady rays mm-hmm kick off the new year
with new gear built to last our friends
at Shady Rays have you covered from the
Sun to the slopes with premium polarized
Shades customizable snow goggles and so
much more shady rays and independent
sunglasses company offers world-class
products that's just as good as any
expensive pair we've worn durable frames
an extremely clear optics for Outdoor
Adventures
that's not all shady Rays offers the
most insane protection of any eyewear
actually every pair of glasses backed by
lost and broken replacement oh that's
sweet
if you lose or break your pair even on
day one they told us they'll send you a
new pair no questions asked whoa boom
you don't have to think about it dude
wear your shitty raised with confidence
because they have your back long after
you've purchased it
wow
look at these
those look great
is it socially acceptable to wear those
just like in this outfit I'm wearing now
for just Insidious [__] yeah dude
nowadays anything goes because my eyes
are real sensitive to the light you know
and I'm trying to protect them they're
hype as [__] dude
I will I will cruise around with the one
with the really reflective one on the
right
the vibe
yeah so um
they have also provided 10 meals
they'll provide 10 meals to fight hunger
in America with every order I love that
and they've donated over 20 million
meals today
bam look good in your gear and feel good
by having an impact well that's lovely
love that shady Rays not shady at all
actually Totally Above board raise
Palms open Rays
important to you uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
if you don't love them exchange for a
new pair or return them for free within
30 days
incredible there's no risk when you shop
with Shady rays and their teams are
always going to have your back so
exclusive for our listeners Shady Rays
is giving out their best deal of the New
Year go to shadyraise.com and use the
code H3 for 50 off
two or more pairs of polarized
sunglasses
there you go try for yourself the shades
rated 5 Stars by over 200 000 people
that's
shadyraise.com code H3 for 50 off two or
more pairs of polarized sunglasses thank
you thank you peace and love peace and
love
[Music]
that shady Ray is a good guy man
Shady Ray love that guy
oh it looks like someone from Guinness
is watching because they just sent us
this award most prolapsed views
from a single podcast achieved December
20. finally by Ethan Klein some
recognition man oh you know I hold that
record
down okay
probably the people in second place may
only have one viewing or two at most
that seems
so um are we ready or do you need a
little more time to set up yeah okay
all right
this is exciting guys you want me to go
first [__] uh no actually because if
we're switching to the popcorn I'm uh
having them get the official time on
that right now 8.2 seconds oh we got it
8.2 seconds so I'm a little bit nervous
just because
I was mentally preparing for the Squirt
Gun Challenge
and I am a good shot
I'm not gonna lie why don't you uh you
could practice a little bit with the
popcorn wall some of us so here it is
how many popcorns six
oh just six okay
is there is there a record holder for
seven
I'm worried about the dogs they can't
eat this
[Music]
um
what all right I'm gonna watch it now
it's on the screen
[Music]
it's got that Aiden Ross Body Language
all right
thank you
so how what are we gonna do about the
doggies here I could
be your brother
Shredder can't have this salty ass [__]
alfredo we can just yell out and say no
but it's better again I've been wrong
what's up oh
this is good this ain't no skin this
[__] has like cheese flavors yes yes yes
mm-hmm
I'm feeling this challenge already
just pick up wait was the original
challenge normal popcorn or cheese
popcorn
got you a question because the cheese
could change the aerodynamics though
well I mean you could do one and you can
have the record for cheese popcorn maybe
you just need to do one now
okay so it's six here's six okay
let me see
okay okay oh
I I have a chance you got a chance
we're saying everybody would get three
attempts
okay I'm just practicing now though
right I think I can actually do it all
right let's do it I think I got this
okay so we're talking throwing six
kernels of popcorn in the mouth in 8.27
seconds
let me put a
block on the screen I'm nervous so so
there's no confusion it's going to be a
Ready set go RC thank you for the 20
gifted
all right Count Me In all right
here we go
ready
set
go
was that sex
well I missed one does that matter it
definitely matters and you didn't make
the time anyways but
it's not a bad not a bad first attempt
you get two more two more shots I got a
shot I really do okay okay thank you
Lena no Lena's like the ball boy at a
tennis game give me give me dings uh
when he hits it okay I okay got it
all right all right here we go attempt
one more time I'm Coming For You Rocco
maybe you should uh line up six good
solid pieces first yeah that's what he
did in a line oh you did no I mean I'm
sorry that's what the guy did okay yeah
there are a couple half pieces in there
no I got it okay bro Ian you what kind
of amateur you take me look I just want
to see you take a dab that's all that's
it Rocco's at home Sweating Bullets
right now oh my God he's sweating uh
Perrier right now or I got Pellegrino
because he's Italian yes nice
[Music]
all right are we ready I'm ready go all
right ready
set go
all right I guess all right that was
much worse that was much worse the first
time I yeah I was practicing was so good
all right chat is pointing out that you
need to not chew he doesn't chew he
doesn't chew and you're hitting a closed
mouth on a couple of those kernels
because you're chewing oh oh it tastes
like beef jerky fantastic tip oh man
you're about to choke
all right this is it I'm ready I'm ready
you ready this is the one yeah yeah all
right last time here we go ready
set
go
all right I think I can confidently say
that our boy took the dub on this one um
with a little practice
no no no no let me just do it this is an
unofficial attempt
dude when the pressure's off yeah what
look at this
okay maybe I was about to say you're a
God but no no no
all right well I'll tell you what we can
uh
we can give you one last crack at the
end you can be practicing while uh the
rest of us take our cookies okay thank
you thank you
ma'am I'm I'm I got my heart rate up
yeah yes yes yes
all right well
I did my best you guys I apologize
for letting go down much like when Aiden
Ross jerked off that's how I feel
[Laughter]
all right who's up next damn
Dan is going to attempt oh baby you want
to come do uh the stopwatch for mine
yeah okay dumping 10 packets of drink
powder
yeah let's see what that means
think you're gonna be impressed
what
that is probably the
wow that's fast though
it's got to be a very valuable member of
a kitchen staff
there's no Rhyme or Reason to the order
yes yes
can you beat that I don't know
we'll show
yeah
Farsi you're going crazy dude I can help
with coping with veterinarian medicine
trauma I've been thinking a lot about
you guys and your sweet tread of I
promise things will work out and
shoulder will have impacted all of our
Lives positively
Ferris is their name is I don't know if
Paris
thank you for saying that
we did a we're about to get the results
of another blood test today actually
Lena can you find out
the results of his blood the second
blood test
[Music]
they did
yeah well it's just some here I'll can
you drop it in like Discord or something
yeah I got it
I'm nervous
make sure there's no personal info Lena
I've been I'm really nervous
he's been doing great
so
my hopes have been up but
I'm just really nervous
what the [__] is this
what the [__] was that
was like an ad that just popped up
thank you Ferris
or I guess Lena's moving it over
so in the meantime now what packs do we
have to pour into the cup
his were quite small
he had like a little salt pack these
ones are big and shout out to uh
gamer sup
who I should be hitting that by the way
it's time to get that dip into myself
I don't think you have a good shot
though the hamburgers your packs are too
big
no this is this is similar size pull it
up again
let's see what he's working okay nice
good news about eyes as it melts
okay let's get a second look at the pack
thank you Zach can you give me some
music or something so there's like yeah
it feels more interesting yeah than what
it is
so if we can examine the pack closely
it's kind of hard he's moving too fast
so fast yeah it looks smaller doesn't it
I don't think also it's paper okay this
one says a good Tearaway option for you
right okay all right I wish you the best
okay
I'm just I'm hoping and dreaming for you
bud
together
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so I'm in my announcer chair
over here so we have six packets
and 10.
of gamer sup
and we have three cups all right
whenever you're ready
um take it away Dan we wish you all the
best I think you got this I'm gonna
count you in Dan ready three two one go
okay Dan is off oh there's powder
everywhere not as easy as it looks does
it damn
I will say he gets powder on the table
too okay there's powder everywhere but
Dan is pouring like a madman
that's three down going on four here
okay he's out on the right cup
interesting approach now on the right
cup again that's
what like five a lot of packets
Dan is focused he's choking on the Miss
on the gamer sup mist
probably not we love gamer stuff but
probably not meant to be inhaled
one more one more stick with it yes 39
seconds wait what what was his time
thank you
are you serious yeah
22 SEC 22.16 seconds dude get out of
here bro
Criminal
and you yeah just I don't want the
powder on the floor because I got I got
it yeah did you send it to me
all right let me look at the results of
this now you got to drink all that then
my heart is like pounding right now
what's up
dude wait this isn't the new one I read
this
this one's all this one is from Monday
you can feel the subs in my throat I
already read that one because we yeah
stuck in my eyes too yeah okay
can you call and see if they have an
update on his blood work because yeah
they did it yesterday okay sweet thank
you
well damn
no
he just didn't I just didn't
Rocco's the goat man
how do you feel was there harder than
you thought it would be
I was really thrown off by like the
stinging sensation in my eyes and I'm
not gonna listen
I'm not gonna take anything away from
Rocco I'm not trying to like undercut
his achievement but
The Gamers up powder in your eyes in the
back of your throat I think it's it
slowed me down a little bit and I feel
this
we need to ask Gamers up if it's FDA
cleared for inhaling right
I'll make a note of that
yeah there's no Powder coming up from
his and also his looks heavier it's like
salt
yeah that's true maybe it is salt
packets yeah yeah nice try though Dan
all right well thank you up next we're
not looking good I'm assuming straight
up too so far
we need at least someone to take the Dub
here ab's coming up next
ah wow this one is one for the bucks
how are you feeling about this here let
me pull up the challenge
this is stacking
Lighters Up not even stacking or
standing oh just standing them up oh
that one's fast it's real fast
let's watch that again
one two three four five wow
yes yes yes
avey's already making excuses
we're drying off the surface obviously
we want this to be as official as
possible
all right whenever you're ready who's on
the timer uh it'll be me so here one
second let me throw that back up
all right AB you got this my friend you
ready all right it'll be a Ready set go
here we go
Ready set go one
oh he's moving slow too what is this
[__] three
or maybe are you even trying
no offense but that was pathetic
what was that wait what was wrong no no
no
I gotta say something
that looked like you were doing it slow
intentionally
oh Dan only got one try
uh well I didn't want to waste like 30
packets of uh camera stuff so all right
so you you got your first try down
how long was his uh it was like over six
seconds the goal is 219. so uh about
three times fast yeah you gotta pick it
up hey let's get these old shaky hands
ready all right here we go all right
attempt number two arako is sweating
Ready set go come on [__] okay all right
one more one more okay I'm gonna have a
mulligan on that if you want just start
again real fast
all right ready Set Go
you're talking
wait I'm not allowed to talk
yeah maybe it's hard
all right here you go Ethan you ready
you want to stand a lighter up real
quick so you get the feel for it yeah
there you go
it's my whole life
all right here we go Ready Set Go
look really slow it was pretty bad it
did look similar to the first attempt
except mine stood up
all right once again ready set
go
oh you started out so strong that time
you started out so strong
all right not even [__] close wow wow
one more one more all right really one
more
this is the last attempt this guy I get
the feeling he really practices yeah
like he's like all day doing this here
we go
Ready Set Go
you got through it what was it though
four seconds point seven eight so you
know I could do it if I practice for
like a week come back in a week let's
see what you got
all right we're next no no no no
but next we got Zach
all right Zach
one arm bottle turnover I have no idea
what that means but let's find out real
quick Chad said we need to see Ian vs AB
in an operation board game
shaky hand boys we'd kill the patient
immediately
I think Zach's gonna be our first Dub
here in the Rocco Olympics
he got a good shot he was killing it off
off camera yeah he was practicing quite
a bit this morning
okay so this is the
one arm bottle turnover let's take a
look
[Applause]
yeah he was uh he was doing it for a
good while this morning
all right well horse Shredder's shaking
I think he got scared from
the lighter
yeah let's go with that we just started
because he knows there's fire inside no
he's just what you're saying he just saw
me slamming things or did he get scared
when you held him Lena
maybe he's just camera shy
he knows how he's not cold he's scared
he gets nervous
[Music]
you see his little Earth shake he wants
us to be a
Rocco
all right Zachy go ahead uh whenever
you're ready
all right we're off to a good start
here is that overhead muted right now
let me unmute it talk a little bit hey
one two one two okay all right the time
to beat is the time to beat
it is 4.06 seconds there it is
so here we go
give you the ready
all right go on go you go on go so Ready
set go
whoa you know what I my hand was not
behind my back okay okay okay that was
fast no you you that was a strong start
your hand motion was smoother than his I
appreciate the Integrity I just want it
to be legit yeah I got you I got you
Rocco's at home [__] he is watching
at the edge of his seat man all right
Zach ready wait hold on Cody what's
wrong
okay all right ready Set Go
wow [__] I missed the stop it was it was
just a shy of uh it was just under three
seconds so I think you actually got it
it was good again it was like 3.8 it it
was definitely under four seconds which
the record was 4.06 so I think you got
it
good job
we could we can review it later to
confirm you want me to do it again Lena
where'd she go
Shredder's scared by what's going on for
some reason I just wanted to take him
outside
we can chill a little bit
all right oh dude no ruin that moment
for you no not at all you want me to do
it again you do kind of ruin it but yeah
no idea do it again do it again
[Music]
I I I'm saying he already has it but if
we want to just I just dropped a
screenshot of the official time oh there
you go that's really good
thank you Cam you blew me out of water
we just uh we've just gone to review
and we were at 3.64 seconds Zachary you
you got the record what was his it was
4.06 wow destroyed destroyed it thank
you thank
you and then Sam can you send that
submit that to the Guinness people yeah
let's get that to Guinness right away
right there bud I'm gonna eat this
thank you all well done can you give us
a yes yes yes yes yes
there it is
or maybe there should be no no no no no
no no no no just to kind of be a foil to
him a new arch nemesis is born to Rocco
he he hates you he's learning everything
about you right now Zach he's doing
research on your whole life he's
learning how to play guitar so that he
can [__] outshred you
right now
yeah this this is this is an important
image right here
this is historic
there it is okay uh next up what do we
got we've got uh uh Olivia hold on I
gotta do something about just hold on
one sec
Papa Ethan's taking Shredder for a walk
around the block he's giving him a nice
little very solemnly walking out of the
set right now yeah he's cuddling him
he's making sure he feels safe and
secure he's being a good Papa to the dog
right there you go
Olivia's record is luckily not as loud
and
scary right
well wait until you see those armbands
when I get snapping I don't know
yeah wait hold on Olivia
go ahead this morning when I was
practicing I did
rubber bands onto
it's been rough it's been rough that
sounds rough
well anyways you guys want to talk about
Avatar
you're [__] right let's talk about it
since Ethan isn't here Sam how hyped are
you go see it this weekend
she's so hyped she says she's so hyped
and am I the only one that liked the
first one
apparently Sam loved the first one which
is why she's saying that she's hyped
um yeah I'm pretty hot I think you two
you haven't seen it yet either
no and I don't think if I don't think I
will look buddy you gotta see it dude
what do you mean you won't
I don't know like I don't like going
outside and [__] like that sitting in a
theater I can sit inside in the theater
thankfully well that's true maybe I'll
do that it's good we're evangelizing it
nice I just want [__] blinking in front
of my eyes cool stuff like this
this is very cool
yeah I wish you had a hydraulic press
compilation though those are my
favorites
yeah I'll work on that actually those
are the best
right yeah I like that one too
[Music]
Olivia how you feeling you confident
you're gonna get this dub against Rocco
no yeah no no Rocco's so good at this
one specifically like I thought that I
would be good because I have practice
with hair because he does this thing I
don't want to give it away but I just
did he uh he does it twice and I feel
like I'm good at that motion
I feel like it could go either way for
you you're doing pretty good off camera
earlier I was trying my best yeah it was
coming out pretty good it's anybody's
game in the Rocco Olympics today
there's a lot of stuff going on around
here right now I don't know what's going
on
I'm just speaking to kill dead air yeah
hi everybody anyone here from Arizona
I need that I really need you to cut my
bangs I really really want to I hate
this middle part look and I feel like
such a goober with a middle part so I
need can you please cut my Banks
tomorrow I'll bring it to serve sorry
guys okay I need to make sure Shredder's
doing okay
freaked me out a little bit how he's
shaking
um
so up next
is Lena's just going to take him out
he's gotten so sensitive he gets so yeah
he used the bathroom I don't know if
that's a he did yeah he went up to Dan's
Car and he shot right in front of it
yeah [__] a lot
oh my God he took a big old dump truck
good for you buddy the whole parking lot
then went back to Dan's Car
um All Right Moving On
so I'm just waiting for Lena I know it's
not the best air time right now no don't
worry I think the shot understands
a lot of love and [__]
well Olivia's going to be doing the
Blindfolded rubber bands actually
saw you practicing before the show
looked pretty good thank you
I think I think it's going to be it's
gonna be tough but possible possible
that's what I like to hear
goodbye Shredder
all right
did we are here let's watch the video
blindfolded rubber bands 13 seconds this
is a long one
to test of endurance yeah
now what is going on here exactly he's
his rubber bands I will say are bigger
than mine he's putting it onto his wrist
and then doubling it and then moving on
yes yes kind of hair it looks like a
hair scrunchie it's just a big rubber
band yeah like a big a big hair tie
rubber band interesting
all right Olivia says no Rocco this is
my record
oh Rocco
thank you
okay
wait what's happening
stop with the gate I don't know what
that means
all right go ahead just pretend like
we're doing a podcast here
this is um a mask that Dan's girlfriend
Ali got me
she did she did she won it for me at
Dave and Buster's oh okay oh wow that
looks like a high ticket item yeah I
know she won it for me at Sam's birthday
all right
all right you good to go
okay I'll give you one finger on a
restart
did he did he do it hold on hold on
let's check here I don't want to give
you a I want your record to be totally
legit I want any questions about yeah
the authenticity so here here's what
he's doing he has both of his hands on
either side okay flat on the table okay
yep
oh yeah
all right
there we go
all right Olivia Ready Set Go
okay going fast oh that could be a
problem that's two oops I have to start
over you knocked one out of place so I I
knew you're gonna have trouble finding
it I don't know
you see that one got all the way up
there
all right let's give it a second you
could probably see he has some more
spread out than you
so they're easier to grab
or not knock you know what I mean she's
been practicing for hours though she's
got the muscle memory okay now it's
going to be a problem not necessarily
successful
we'll see all right ready
set go here we go off to a fast start
one two oh yeah Lightning Fast great
form three four
okay you're the ones in the middle is
the one you missed I'm gonna I don't
know if that's cheating
because I knew that was gonna be a
problem for her but
time I mean okay okay so it's a decent
time I'm afraid you didn't make it 15.9
but it's pretty good what it was
13.09 [__] because that one was fast
dude have you beat him in your training
she did it first I have she beat it this
morning wow yep so it's definitely
possible it's like when Tonya Harding
did the triple Axel just like that
thank you
all right let's give it another attempt
all right one more time this is it right
uh technically if you want to count the
first one then yes this is this is the
third attempt
Olivia's getting in the right uh
headspace as a true competitor
she's placing the rubber bands correctly
getting her mind in order
you gotta avoid those Tangles of course
yeah you gotta untangle make sure to
breathe make sure to breathe how's your
breathing yeah my breath reading feels
um actually steady good good study's
good it feels natural that's what you
want
all right last attempt Olivia give it
all you got all right here we go Ready
set go okay here she's off she's off
she's going fast oh oh okay all right
she's in looks like she stumbled a
little bit on the third one but she's
making good time wow making up time here
on a really fast entry there five one
more
six stop
so unfortunately
it was over 16 seconds wow you know what
man you gave it your heart and soul you
really was a passionate competitor right
and you're up against the best so don't
feel good Morocco good game
you know
it is what it is
wow so so far we've only beat one it's
hard this guy's good at what he's so
good yeah he's really good good he's a
world-class athlete dude here uh Sam oh
Sam is actually I think been practicing
this quite a bit too Sam how are you
feeling
I'm nervous honestly I've it's Hit or
Miss I've beat it twice but I'm not
feeling confident at the moment well
what Sam is up against is moving grains
of rice into a cup this is the
incredible feat
of uh dexterity and speed
this man is moving grains of rice into a
cup
not one not two but ten
10. oh my God how are you gonna beat
this I'm kind of nice with chopsticks
better be you better be more than nice
to beat Rocco the the time to beat is
13.05 seconds here okay this is exciting
now Sam you got the rice out you got
your cup out oh we got that overview
this is a this is official I believe in
you Sam I think you got this all right
Sam are you prepared
I am like my heart is racing settle your
settle your heart breathe breathe yeah
breathe this is not a big deal it's just
a world record
okay
yeah listen to corpse husband all right
here we go Ready Set
go okay Sam is oh fast she's going fast
that's two
it's like little bugs they hop in there
she's going fast this is super good yo
Sam go dude that you had the one I think
you got it really yeah
no way
okay hold on let's go back to the replay
dude you that's got to be your best
performance right of all your practices
that was insane you needed the pressure
that was incredible you needed the high
heart
this morning yeah yeah you do not choke
under okay well let's grab a frame and
watch and let's compare it for an
official ruling but Sam I'm feeling
pretty good you got first you got that
for me I can't believe it leave a shot
years right [__] go Taco is screaming
no no no he punch you he just punched a
hole in the wall
no no no no my message for him is cope
cope and sees Rocco they'll have enough
go have a cappuccino Italian [__] El
duoco
blocko
locko locko so we're going here okay
we've got an official ruling thank you
Cameron that's the moment The Rice hit
the cup the judges are reviewing right
now it looks like you're on fire too Sam
like you just
blew this [__] up
there it is that's 11 53 what was his
score
uh his was uh 13 something oh my wow wow
uh 1305. I don't even know if he can
beat you dude I'd love to see him try no
[__] shot okay so okay you're gonna
have to submit your own record to
Guinness to get the award money and the
plaque yeah
all right now Cameron is up next oh yes
yes yes well we got two dubs for the
crew and I I'm already happy with the
results of that
but Cameron is coming in with one of the
most
um competitive I want to say one of the
I would say one of his star performances
of Rocco's
of course this is the uh world famous
stabbing bread with skewers challenge
yeah I when I first saw this I thought I
was gonna get it easy but then I was
practicing this morning could go either
way that's a nice looking bread it is it
smells very nice looking baguettes maybe
we should crack into that after this
cut going for you early here all right
so let's watch the master go first
hand behind the back now his spread
looks softer than yours and bigger so
it's easier to hit I'm just saying
how can you tell how soft it is it looks
strong I feel like you could tell how
soft it is because I know those ones are
hard the French rolls and this Bread's
been out all morning let me get let me
pop a feel it's crazy
I see there's a ton of holes in them
from your vigorous practice yeah yeah
he's got a practice loaf of course I'm
gonna say this those are really stale
and not easy to impale
so if you beat him
that's all I got let me remove the stage
hazards real quick all right Cameron the
time to beat is
7.05 seconds
oh dude you got that Royal Tenenbaum
yeah definitely and said I look Italian
wearing this I thought he was trying to
get into the mindset yeah exactly coming
for you gotta know your enemy all right
the clock is on the screen Cameron are
you ready I'm ready Ready set go okay
camera oh he's stabbing fast oh the
angle of attack is interesting no okay
okay no okay oh no so here's what I want
to do for you Cam okay I don't think it
would be because his bread is flatter
and bigger and it doesn't
doesn't slide like yours did now I would
be okay putting some kind of weight
behind the bread so it doesn't slide we
got weights and bread let's do it
weights and bread
is that you got something heavy there
Sam yeah
just a little something to help just to
emulate the way the girthiness of his
bread yeah we can tape it down or
something
I don't want to give you too much of an
advantage to your camera it's not very
girthy
but you can keep putting [__] back there
the watch goes on the bigger headband
keeping shoes back there maybe put some
of those uh V8s you can put on there
this is a little weighted yeah okay I
think that's okay
kind of tall though you're obscuring the
the skewers this is critical okay oh
he's gonna hold the bread wow now let me
debate this here he didn't have any
slide he had a lot less slide so I don't
know if this is giving you an unfair
Advantage but let's go with it I mean
he's known to be a cheat too so he's a
[__] cheater yeah we don't need to
give him the benefit of this he probably
has Gorilla Glue you're right [__] him
Marco's a cheating hack all right all
right I'm ready for round two though
idiot all right
go ahead cam Ready Set go all right
Cameron's coming fast he's coming hard
oh he's fast he's fast the hands
sturtedly behind his back oh a little
hiccup at the end but
interesting interesting very interesting
now I stopped it
right as he was doing the last dab but
it hiccuped so time was 6.4 which did
beat the record however
I don't think I can really give it to
you not official well well so I get one
more then in a way that's an operating
here it's an operating error I will take
the blame for that we could review it
it's close I think do it again and I
think you got it I think you got it I
think you got it
that's it only one more week this is my
third chance right well that I think
that one was kind of a that that's
operator that's on me but I think you
did great cam yeah you got this
the bread is really just a lot harder
too I can't I have to emphasize that
thing is like
a brick
it feels it feels thicker than before
too
all right Cam's getting all ready I
think this is it I think we have a new
world record on our hand we'll see may I
suggest some virgin bread go ahead love
Miss what you got why don't you start
putting the thingies in on the from the
left side that way you don't shoot your
[__] screen is crazy love I can't
switch up my method right now you've got
it wait let me see you deep love he's in
too deep hold on let me see so what do
we got today we got the is that what's
going on the top left what is she
cutting I can't stop staring at it it's
soap cutting there's a subway runner
there's a kinetic sand there's Temple
Runner there's
um
hydraulic press that's for cam too thank
you I just felt like if you started from
the left side you wouldn't have to like
dude this is awesome this is actually
kind of a Vibe I'm not even it's not
even funny like that's sick dude yeah
I've been sitting here just watching my
my own screen for a while looking like a
fidget toy yeah and then I'm looking at
the soap one that's my favorite so far
but sometimes I get bored and I look
over at the kinetic sand one
it's wonderful I like this one the most
because he's actually this is good like
this is no no peasant gameplay this is a
good Subway gamer yeah that's high
quality Elite subway runner I wonder if
you'll see him jump over that'll Rock up
dude he's cracked as [__] look here he
jumps over the bridge he jumps over the
bridge it's some high tech
a real
thought that I had yesterday and I noted
it in my brain
ly you guys I was watching a true crime
video and I was like oh I need to be
paying attention to the words so that I
can follow the story because when I
watch Like Parks and Rec or something
like that I know the story so I can be
scrolling on Twitter and I was like oh I
need to be playing like Flappy dunk
right now so that I can hear the words
that she's saying to me on screen yes I
love that it's a routine that I go
through
well we're really [__] aren't we
yeah I can whenever you're ready all
right not whenever you're ready when I
count you in here we are Cameron
Ready set go okay Cam's off to a strong
start oh he's going fast no hiccups and
he's got this one and oh he stabbed it
in one of the sticks stopped his hand
you guys
you have one more one more okay yeah
because because there was an operating
there we're not gonna hold that against
you that's a stage Hazard though no Dan
stopped the clock early and then we
didn't have an official time yeah yeah
and I don't blame you Dan I mean I
thought it was over too it seemed like
it was over yeah I'm airing on the side
it's a chatter correctly pointed out
error on the side of counting over
because we can always go to tape right
but it doesn't go the other right so
I'll I'm getting a little bit more
generous with the stop no okay Cam this
is you you got this now careful of the
hazard that you just yeah
into consideration though all right all
right you got this ready
set go right okay I'm stabbing the bread
one two he's going fast he's going fast
and he's staying on the right side he's
adopting oh
they're all punched up and it was over
whatever I mean I'll take that I'll take
the L cam is taking the L it hurts
because you're so close listen listen
you know what listen to me with enough
time we can actually verify that one all
we need to do is take the video file
let's verify that one drop it into
Premiere the thing is I can't cut the
record until after so love can oh [__]
right if you have a way to live clip it
love can you well I mean you could just
scream yeah just go back at the go watch
the live replay can you work on that
yeah can you work on that love record it
Go frame and then go frame by frame and
try and get an exact time on that
attempt that he Seated on
all right you're good Kim I think you
actually beat him I think you just we're
gonna we're gonna go to the official on
that one but I think you actually might
have beaten him well if I beat him this
I'll give a preemptive yes yes yes I
lost yes good game Rocco yep
Rocco you coward all right love working
on that we will we will report back as
soon as we have an official judgment I
would like to see Rocco do something
more interesting like
how much crack can you smoke in a
10 second period the deepest crackhead
yeah
I have smoked crack before once have you
I can't believe that's never comes up on
the show no I know most people are
surprised by that but I have
were you ever by chance number one on
Wiki feed or any other kind of
impressive accomplishment I was yes yes
have any lawsuits against any media
Mogul yes okay thank you
all right so we're gonna with the juries
out on cam but Ian is coming up and this
one sounds tough this one sounds
notorious this is the spinning four
coins at the same time that's never been
done before
and he's got n to flex on you in he's
got his Guinness plaque out on this one
let's see it over there
isn't Peak physical condition obviously
foreign
I originally picked this one because I
was like you got to be kidding me that's
so stupid yeah and then I started trying
it getting a fourth one because we you
got to beat his record he only did three
right so four spinning at one doing four
getting to the fourth before the first
one starts to fall
it's tough It's a lot tougher than it
looks so I abandoned it and Ian actually
he's like I can do that and he is pretty
good at the coin spinning so you've been
practicing Anne uh I practiced a little
before the show yeah okay did you come
close to his record
I did it you did oh yeah all right this
is exciting uh AB can you come do the
time for this one yeah go swim but this
one has
okay so it's not this one's not timed
it's just
what is physically possible what can man
do and that's why Rocco does this we
want to push man to the limits to find
what is possible what is achievable man
has gone to the Moon can we spin four
coins at the same time
we just don't know
okay Ian is preparing to switch with Dan
thank you Dan thank you AB doing a
little musical chairs back here
here comes the great competitor now Ian
is no stranger to competition Here Comes
Mr verified who defeated
the whole crew and competition
stepping up to the plate okay now now
did you beat the record or come close to
it and practice I had all four of these
active wow but that's never been done
before
well
my hand trimmer is what's going on with
this sweatshirt
Dan's gone he's up Dan is out of the
switching seat
it's not your fault damn it it's not
your fault don't sweat it
all right Dan is running back to the
Switcher
thank you I'm sorry about that Ian
that's just item now I'm trying to throw
you if I mess up now we know what
happened
all right what what were you saying
before uh well my my hand trimmer is
gonna kick in worse because it's the
pressure so I'm gonna have to battle
that can you do us a favor put your
hands out let's see how steady you're
holding today
that looks pretty good that looks like
pretty steady today [__] My Thumb Thumbs
acting a little he's going rogue
okay can I ask you something do you take
medicine to calm that or are you just
all natural I tried and I didn't feel
like it was that it didn't do enough to
Warrant it yeah no but I'm still gonna
kick Rocco's ass does it bother you the
hand trimmer it doesn't bother me I
don't notice it yeah everyone else
notices it though so that part is
annoying yeah I'm not I mean now that I
know you and no I don't even think about
it either but people think I'm like
nervous all the time yeah right that's
got to be frustrating it's like oh man
he's so nervous what's wrong with them
yeah yes yes yeah I'm just terrified
with everything so
real quick yes love am I seeing am I
seeing that we do we have an official
ruling
no
all right
so I thought we did am I bad no well I
can't record well no I can't do it for
my PC right now I need oh I can't do it
probably
all right uh we'll work on that but Ian
it's your time now okay four coins at
once never been done ready I'll count
you down here I guess we don't need a
timer it's just oh that's true you just
hit overlay four Dan and it'll take
it thank you okay guys okay ready
okay we got one spinning we got two
spinning what oh I hope they don't
Collide one's about to fall off okay
that almost okay that was an arrow that
was an error yes are you ready
okay one's up two's up threes up that's
oh the fourth one took out the third one
okay and just a terrible accident okay
you can do this I can do this I can do
this
here he goes one is up with a beautiful
spin two almost went down bad stand it's
a bad time go one more go one more yeah
you're so close you're so close Ian
ah Bad spin oh no now there's just coins
flying everywhere give me one you got
this you got this dude one's up two's up
three is going slightly ah that was
it's so close go go go go you got this
we need another dog for the crew
one that's a big spin two
three oh you got this you got this that
oh that I don't know
I don't think so man the fourth one was
[__] wasn't spinning it was falling we
need a sturdy spin
that's one
two
three this is it this is it oh no I've
even fell off in it okay yeah yeah yeah
one more again one more come on
you got this big spin
Second Spin looking good good momentum
oh no the fourth one takes out the third
one again I choked the fourth every time
do you ever consider flicking it
oh okay
is this bad is this bad uh no I mean I
mean no people are very close and
everyone's rooting for you one
two okay this looks good this is strong
this is strong
the fourth one is just haunting foreign
Don't Stop Don't Stop
I'm not a breath
I said you were doing PE you got to be
fast because that last one that first
one was not strong no the first one was
falling what the first one was not a
strong spelling yes
I tried to warn you no it was not I'm
trying I just listen I want this for you
that's good oh God
can you guys just come back later all
right we kind of need that uh table too
three
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you did it
[Applause]
wow Rafa you [__] [__] ass loser
wait how could you can't see me I'm
sitting here but you can't see me
yeah can you go back to your main street
thank you Rocco you've been [__] had
you loser you charlatan
shame on you
yeah that was interesting because the
third one
went down popped back up
and but all four were definitely
spinning there as you close it out wow
Ian with another dub under his cap
thank you thank you
Ian how's it feel to just win so much
man the winning never stops
sometimes you know you feel like you're
gonna get tired of it but then nope
still rules still rules still out there
wow I'm proud of you guys man that's
three dubs for the crew here
super super impressive now Lena this is
your moment
huge huge huge one
uh for Marco one of the biggest yeah
this one is the of course
moving water via a sponge
and to a beaker as everybody knows
well let's see what does his sponge look
like
he's using like kind of just a standard
I think the one on your left hand the
pink one yeah I think that's more like
what he's using no let's see it because
I when I checked it out it looked like
oh for real
can we get a call on the sponge shape
[Music]
um
standard yeah it seems like a standard
issue sponge yeah is your theory that
the other one absorbs more definitely
really
but I when I was looking at it it looked
more like this sponge but either way it
doesn't matter well hold on let's try to
get a closer look if we can because this
is going to make a big difference
[Music]
what are we ruling here it looks
standard to me I don't know what kind of
fancy sponges they have in Italy
if I see this he doesn't he doesn't hit
strike me as someone who uses fans
sponges but this isn't fan this is
standard also
Chad seems to be saying use the pink one
yeah that's that's what I'm gonna say
too I'm sorry no fair enough I also want
to point out that his bucket seems to be
lower so which requires less movement
but let's see what you can do yeah that
should be fine but here let's watch the
king do it first and um yeah
okay so he's
transferring the water
my question is does he just invent these
uh how do you even think to do this
I'm gonna use a sponge to transfer water
yes yes yes
I feel I feel confident
because I think he started inside right
oh no you know what his was probably wet
though because he's been practicing so
he actually has the double-sided sponge
yeah
oh that is a thick one he also has
a picture of the yellow
yellow foreign
in fact I would even say after getting
this shot of it that his is bigger than
yours Yeah well yeah but as long as I
feel this will absorb as much maybe all
right if you're feeling confident then I
I support you okay
I feel super confident now
yeah it's the bottom of the tape as soon
as it touches the bottom of that tape
wait how did you guys determine how much
to put in that's 5
5 oh 500 mils okay
all right okay all right you got this
thank you Lena you feel ready I
feel we we're
he starts above right there where his
hand is that's where he starts so I'm
ready
okay wait hold on his is not dripping
water I think you gotta squeeze that out
oh yeah I agree I think he's he's going
in drive he starts with a dip yeah he's
going in dry all right I'm gonna give
you a Ready set go sure Ready set go
okay lean is in maybe a false start a
little bit but that's okay let's see
just the bottom is scooping like a
monster
she did it I got it yeah that seems
that was you you blew it away so there's
something
funny business going on here hmm
I do think you'll beat him Lena
but why don't you do it so much faster
his sponge is not scooping as much
she's been doing dishes for like a
family for years actually that's why I
picked this one over the the um okay how
about this you know sponges how about
this you destroyed him with the big
sponge now show him what's up and
destroy him with the others there you go
if you could do it with the other one
you're Undisputed yeah Undisputed chance
is it possible that
he's doing more liquid or you're pretty
sure that's 500 mL wow okay uh dump it
back into the bucket
yeah and just you know
good
all right guys and we're going to go and
dry now so this is all good all right
going in dry if I'm nervous but I think
you got this thanks
all right
here we go Lena
ready
set
go all right Lena's in there
yeah see this one's going slower but it
doesn't matter I think you can do it I
think you can do it
I don't know you got it you got it don't
don't falter it's soapy but it's like
soapy I'd say I think yeah that's it you
did it and you're still under 16. I
think you blew it away
[Applause]
yes you
yes yes
you earned that man thank you oh and
going back to cams we have the final
verdict on time it was sick wait six
seconds six by 24 seconds what was the
time to beat on the bread stab
uh it was just above seven you beat him
by half a second yeah it was yes
7.05 so yeah he got it oh you got it
people he he's dropping like he's
dropping dude you're nothing Rocco do
you understand we're destroying you you
can turn into Ash and Rubble no your
life is a [__] lie bro no I'm just
kidding I don't know why so Zach did it
Sam did it cam did it Ian did it and
Lena did it is that right
that sounds right to me at least four so
that's five out of nine
and I'm very proud of the crew and I'm
excited to announce that we have five
Guinness World Records right here in our
very office that's right what other
podcasts can claim such a feat yes yes
yes none
incredible stuff huh
unbelievable
unbelievable can we uh can we all hit a
yes yes at the same together sure count
us in all right three two one yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes oh wait oh that
oh hold on maybe start oh what's the
problem what's his delay what's Love's
delay it's about a half a second how
about we do it with love here we're
gonna do three that's what I'm trying to
do we're gonna do three two and then
when I say one love you say it but then
everybody else says it after one and I
think it'll line up just right so you
ready for that here we go wait hold on
hold on hold on go back to love screen
that's so interesting wow it's on the
top left they're like
you know what you need
yeah no sidewalk power washing oh yeah
oh my God
sidewalk power washing you know you know
Dan is so right love Yeah you could
probably drop like the driving one for
the power wash no no we have a room
we have plenty okay so let's get it in
there
yeah it's gonna take some time next time
you come to me people saying just have
love countdown bruh the delay goes both
ways yeah it doesn't it doesn't work
like that it's this game either way all
right so you understand love you're
you're going on on one the rest of us
are going after one and it's gonna line
perfectly here we go yeah yeah all right
yeah so the yes yes yes in three two one
yes yes yes yes yes okay let's close to
it a little E I think a little a little
earlier if I count down what if I count
down I doesn't work I I mean but you
hear me in the real time let's try it
you count down let's try it one two
three yes yes I've been I guess he's
gonna hear it delayed but the audience
okay so there you go love we got it yes
yes yes
yes yes yes we just yes yes yes destroy
that whole man's career
he's over delete his account okay well
here it is uh super fun super great he
and Ian was showing me yesterday that
people have stepped up and tried to take
on his challenge but then he redoes the
challenge to beat there that's what I
want to see yeah he gets very defensive
yeah I think we're gonna be we're gonna
initiate a war here maybe we can uh from
the podcast account take clips of all of
our records and do at him on the podcast
account oh that way he'll see them all
yo that's like flexing on him
we know what we need to do I need to
break his legs like Nancy kyrgym yeah
yeah yeah so they can't compete yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes
except every limb so we can't do any of
them
hey Rocco maybe don't retry those
records it's coming out something down
my leg something bad might happen to you
and it get hot I got a lot of I got
hairy legs bad things happen to people
every day
people they've tripped and fall on the
subway
they fall they break their fingers
things happen to people
fastest dude to stab a piece of bread 10
times
by Dr Cameron G Grant PhD I gotta make
one for everybody now
wow
well thank you thank you let's move on
the balls in your the Breads in your
court Rocco
yeah I saw this post on the subreddit
you know how we always read out like the
there's lots of ladies in the audience
who are trying to meet dudes on Tinder
and when they tell them they're an H3
fan
all hell breaks loose
well here's a new one I haven't seen
she says actually they seem to be making
a nice connection right they're they're
they're having a good time I love last
podcast on the left I'll entertain pod
save America but they are not my thing
he's he's
he's hard to uh to entertain there last
pockets on the left is my [__] okay and
here comes the big question do you
listen to the H3 podcast at all
I don't listen because I used to work
with Ethan and he's just a little weird
to me
she says I'm sorry what I used to work
with Ethan yeah I used to do a lot in
the YouTube world and I helped him with
his early live stream stuff
now
I've been taking this serious as I can I
says who's Michael because she put his
name in as Michael at the top
and I'm trying to think like
what's the accusation here by the way he
says I was weird to him or I'm weird to
watch
like because I he says I haven't I used
to work with Ethan and he is just a
little weird for me
little too weird for me so
was he saying that I was weird to him
when he worked with me I don't think so
that finds your humor too weird okay
that's not really even an insult I mean
I think he's not like pulling your
nipple out in the middle of the show and
being like sun's out bro whatever bro
you obviously don't understand
yeah okay but yeah I'm like see this is
a new one saying that they know me now
and
I I don't know any [__] Michael I
gotta say I'm trying to be I'm trying to
give this guy the benefit of the doubt
Ethan and I are like we're really
racking our brains trying to think if
like some intern that we briefly had or
just somebody at uh who worked at twitch
when we were streaming on Twitch maybe
but I went and searched through my
emails from the earlier like the podcast
I did yeah and nobody that before you
Dan there wasn't many but there was um
we the producer we had before you or he
was just freelance he wasn't full-time
he's just helping us what was his name
Carlos Carlos yeah Carlos was the guy
that brought me in so I know it's not
him yeah and then before that there was
but I forget his name but I don't think
it was Michael well maybe it was that I
don't think it was Michael okay I'm in
yeah I wouldn't know well did you ever
live stream before the podcast was that
your friend no I live streamed but it
was just like me and Ela and my
underwear and our living room like right
there was no one you didn't have anybody
come help you clearly nobody was helping
me
oh I mean it's probably
[Music]
you know it's a really small group of
people that I've worked with
professionally so it's a kind of a tough
lie to get away with here
it seems so Random to lie about because
he's not even trying to get clout from
it because he's like I don't even I
don't I don't really like him he's weird
yeah yeah
it's not even like he's trying to expose
me or has inside info right he's like I
usually lying
well Michael Wherever You Are
I wish you well
I'm sorry it didn't work out for being
so weird yeah sorry that I'm such a
weirdo but I wish you well I haven't
there's no bad blood between us and uh
if you're watching or I guess apparently
you aren't
because I'm too weird
that uh you are enjoying your non-weird
podcasts oh Michael who's a 10-month
member said he's Michael Michael Ethan
straight farted as I was setting up his
mic that I mean that tracks that
attracted my experience
yeah I saw someone from Michael Corleone
donated or remembered
wait what is this cam oh oh it was
Vsauce it was V socks okay that makes
sense uh can you imagine Vsauce he's
married by the way so that would be a
bit scandalous yeah he was on Tinder
and also he's probably the weird one of
the weirdest dudes alive so
I think I don't think he called me weird
somebody said what about your son uh
Michael Michael and Trevor guys I'm not
42 and my son's names are not Michael
and Trevor I know who they are and I
appreciate
if you guys stopped
[Music]
[Applause]
congrats man
and many more
37. it's a good age
it is but I'm not 42. bro Jackie
Robinson
great [__] number wow yeah well I'll
be 42 someday God willing and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy 42 I
believe is the the answer to the meaning
of the universe right and I'll let you
know when I am 42. oh and 42. great
great movie uh featuring Chadwick
Bozeman I'm 42. my breast impossible's
age you know one of my favorite tool
songs 46 and 2 42. that's not even it's
close enough but I don't even need to
defend it because I'm not even 42. or I
will be God willing someday and I'll
come in and I'll say guys here's what it
feels like but today I'll tell you what
it feels like to be 37 which is my age
shame on you guys you know it's in ages
it's funny you say that you're 37
because you said something about being
37 in this video right here if you want
to check that time stamp oh great what
is Cam got cooking up now I've been
holding on to this one
I'm not that old 37 is the new 50s or I
mean no 37 is a new 20. [__] you said
it
what you said 37 is the new 50. 37 is
the new 50. so I didn't realize you were
50.
that's not at all whatever all right
I see what I did wrong there yeah that's
not what I meant just to be clear it's
50 50.
all right guys stop it
so once I go on no jumper and then get
atom 22 on your show I don't think so I
think that guy's
I don't think he's a fan
I don't think he's someone that you want
to associate with is from what I
understand without saying specifically
because I don't know what's real and
what's not so I don't want to put
something out there that's not true
but that was a Trisha era thing so I
actually I have to question everything
she taught me and like what is the truth
about M22
foreign
let's ask him live
he's here right now let's bring him out
welcome Adam 22.
yeah here you know I love wild Barber
videos this guy's on the on another
level we appreciated
this looks like it's in India too
and is it or is it maybe like uh
Iraq or something yeah I know it's not
Indian
so we saw the Indian Barbers who were
other Turkish okay okay
or no yeah the Indian Barbers were the
ones that like those hair uh hair on
fire yeah they light their hair on fire
and I was so taken by that we did it
right now here is their Barbers who is
trying to waterboard him with soap and
grind the whole top layer of skin off
his face also trying to make him deaf
too slaps his ears
I don't know what that is like he's just
spray painting his face okay dude he's
not a dirty dish
he's straight he's scraping him like a
dirty oven
rack
this is probably like Greece Degreaser
they sprayed on his face
[Applause]
it cannot feel good that is just horrid
dude okay that's my fave baby
attacks the head
he's putting parmesan cheese on him for
some reason
I'm not sure that
[Music]
okay the water we like that that's right
you think he's done no
okay moving out to the dominatrix
portion of the haircut
[Applause]
dude I would so do this I would
definitely do it I would try it there's
one thing here that I'm I've some doubts
about the authenticity of hold on
dude he's like a professional retailer
watch this he shot he's trying to jump
in his head
like there's muscles in there now
explain the efficacy of karate chopping
his head look at this from the back to
his [__] head
so I would definitely do that dude same
here I would I would absolutely [__]
loved it but I have a feeling like
anyone who doesn't have like the old dad
skin because I feel like at a certain
age or when you're like this guy you
could do anything your skin it always
looks the same but when you're like our
age and you're still kind of like or I
mean they're not like I mean you have
like 30. you're 42 and you have eczema
dude what are you doing I'm 25 years
well that's kind of what I'm saying is
if you put like Degreaser and a brush on
your face you'll never be the same like
your skin will be [__] up for life
when he's doing the scrubbing on the
[__] ear like he's cleaning like the
crevices in a rim on a car like he's
getting like what I'm saying it reminds
me of like he's detailing a car he gets
all the different aspects of his body oh
God
I love it so there it is shout out to
our what I believe to be
potentially Turkish Barbers out there uh
The Barbers of the world shout out red
the hell
also I want to give an acknowledgment I
was meaning to give this guy a nod since
Christmas
this is an Indian dude I believe and he
took over you guys copyright check this
yeah yeah he took over Tick Tock with
this wonderful and cheery holiday song I
want to play for you guys
cheers
[Music]
that is English by the way is it yeah
all of his videos he's singing in
English
that one here the comments are pretty
funny they go chestnaz Robin
oh [__]
so also
I have questions about the filter on his
face my theory is that he looks nothing
like this this looks like one of those
100 filters
foreign
[Music]
it's
so enchanting
um his name is James Merck wait no this
is a re-upload no it's under I think
right
here he has got some other bangers check
this one out
people started putting them in like
green screens all over Tick Tock with
this one
[Music]
he's going tonight
what's his actual Channel this one I
work I Nook
yeah his name is dude his hair is fired
too look at this [__]
[Music]
okay call me Scrooge shut up
what the [__] was that I'm watching this
is some uh know your main page oh we
love know your man but what was his name
again
a Nook what I'm trying to find his real
page oh you found it
thank you to fari what was it again
fairies fairies
[__]
okay here he is here's the legend yo
look at his profile pic
Audi
I see I sing in a nuke's language that
came from my heart
so let's take a look here
we have to be careful with some of this
copyrighted music oh my gosh we might
just see that beautiful
yeah I don't know I'm on his Instagram
and show me he looks beautiful okay he's
glowing also he's getting comments from
the official uh was it smeal app the app
that lets you transform your voice like
that okay let me take a look at this by
the way the um dude this is super
photoshopped bro I don't know his eyes
are not his eyes look [__] up as [__]
his face is like totally mutated but his
whole face is Magic if you saw this face
in real life you would [__] run okay
look at the one how big they are for his
face the one I just signed
that ain't right dude you're telling me
Oh yeah wait y'all [__] with me now
look at his shoulders sorry not
beautiful
what the [__] is happening a Nook oh he
gets a lot of likes or wait is these
Jimmy Lee likes or real likes
I think you could even see the face tune
in the background of that last one where
he like bent the couch see now I really
want to know what he looks like because
look yeah that that is not him
that face tune his face is 100 different
I think it might just be colored
contacts in his eyes no his face this
bro I'm telling you he's just like some
normal ass looking dude
dude find me I need to know what he
looks like he needs to call him look at
this [__] wait this is a different
person though
that's Michaela
he needs to call in he can still do the
face filter though sorry beautiful
I found like the lowest rest picture of
him without a filter I think oh really
yeah it's like super tiny though
okay all right let's take a look here
but that's definitely no filter right
I don't know it definitely looks realer
than the other ones and he's definitely
still glowing yeah he's beautiful
gorgeous voice too
Strummer slapping in this room that's
right
yeah so I was bopping at this over
Christmas break
and uh
face age
okay
oh dude come on bro
dude his face filter is insane
wow
there's my boy
maybe
um
okay we found another candid one of them
hold on getting to the bottom of this
so so what's the story here
this is one of his first uh Instagram
posts it seems like it's a few posts
away from when he discovered facetune
that one I mean yeah I see the
resemblance for sure
he's handsome
the Cleaver's throwing me off a little
bit you're right about the eyes if it's
not a filter their contacts or something
because it looks like he has brown eyes
in this photo it also looks like he
hadn't found his style yet in that photo
I think that we should cut he's finding
his footing that's fine oh we got more
receipts okay
yeah can you just play the mute that
song for me on a loop Zach
uh yeah I can do it and I think whenever
something Cherry comes up just hit us
with that what is this
doing like a cooking tutorial
uh I think maybe
bro I I don't know the way he's holding
that butcher knife is not looking like
by the way you were wondering if he was
Indian at I think I think this is Thai
these letters that guy's time when he is
it doesn't look like it
well at least I guess I am not the
authority like
you thought the Turkish guy was Indians
yeah yeah I don't know [__] I'm an idiot
yo no shot bro
look at this one you guys that's our
boys
is it yeah yeah okay this is our boy
oops
show
yeah
oh that's completely right two comments
on this one is I think he's using the ab
Photoshop app for one
definitely that center line is off no
dude he just takes 100 the meanest
[__] happy trail I've ever seen in my
life it looks like AI generated like
what is that [__] Lost Woods man dude
it's just from liver pills that's all it
is it's all Natty he's special and
perfect and he glows wait genuinely that
I know it's not even his body but like
the Happy Trails actually confusing do
dudes look like dessert dudes with like
hair like that it looks like a centaur
where just horse body starts there I've
never seen hair like that oh
what does his dick look like it must be
dude he got cube Forest that's where Bin
Laden was hiding he's upside down like
Voldemort on his dick right there really
it's like the bottom of a beard
when he drops trout this is what you
hear
just imagine you're in bed the fireplace
is crackling
come here baby
it's time to make love his shirt opens
he pulls down his pants
a massive Chia Pet bull covers his belly
button down to his ball sack
you have to dig in to find
no no no no no not that one
damn bro
so far top comment is you guys I'm fact
Checker and I'm telling you right now
this is not edited
haters will say it's engine
this is awesome dude he's my fave and
look
my boy
we love you forever dog
I'll always remember you for sure
there's no slurping on the phone
benchmeyer
his photos are edited his voice is
edited
yo you wouldn't say that about his voice
no literally if you go to that first
picture I sent here I'll send it the the
voice changing app commented on him
saying we love you
oh they did they really expose him what
so wait is this even a real person at
this point right voices at it his face
is this the AI maybe he is AI generated
I have big balls maybe he's made by the
same people who do little Michaela
that's fine you can make money
legitimately with this yeah
okay here he wrote so tell me if this is
like AI generated text please read I
think our world is Multicultural
multilingual I just want to sing in
English which is not my native language
it's natural for it to be offbeat and
funny but there are many people in the
world okay he does not speak that
eloquently because listen to how he says
itches not slurping on a suburbs well
it's different he probably uses the
Google translator yeah
the grammar is like perfect like usually
when you translate it reads a little odd
yeah I mean if he's coming from I don't
know there's like AI shakers though
online you can just copy paste it and
see if it's a yeah but just chat GPS or
whatever [__] it's called why did we not
get access to that what is the hang up
everybody and their aunt has access to
this JJ isn't it just open to the public
what do you mean no I tried to get on
and it said you have to send us an email
I was like hey it's Ethan from the
biggest podcast in the world can we
[__] promote it
I don't know
it's open now at least it is yeah wait
the shot bolts yeah people are using all
over the place oh wait it's how is it
chat you're gonna have to log into PPT
yeah
I want to see if he can write something
oh I have to log in and [__] [__]
damn it yeah
[Music]
um
this is interesting I don't know what it
means
[Music]
but it is interesting
the triangle I don't really understand
it's got it it's his Happy Trails yeah
Baltimore was on the back of Quill's
head we're saying interesting Harry
Potter Whaler alert
I assume that's a spoiler
oh [__] so I Nook my boy my man
thank you for this holiday classic move
over Mariah Carey enough is in town
All I Want for Christmas Is Enough a
Nook is the queen of Christmas the new
queen of Christmas
ain't that the truth man I'm drunk
you're slurping over who lasts near her
cheers
I would like more than just this clip I
want the whole song
I'll uh I'll look out for it but I'll
take what I can get
all right let's move on to some drama
this episode's been too drama free
episode's been too fun it's been way too
fun let's let's bomb everybody out and
have a bad time this isn't real drama
it's Nick ocado drama right on drama
drama alert Jim trembler
this is Nick ocado uh beef so it's just
fun beef so where did this live these
guys made this podcast and then they
were what did they say about me that
they were Nick was lying about the
conditions he wanted to come here under
right
uh uh it wasn't I wouldn't go as far as
to say he was lying it was
obscuring the truth slightly okay Dan in
my world we call that lying
it's because it wasn't just like
outright making stuff up it was like
stop [__] lying all right so here it
is here's their talk they're responding
to us I don't remember what we said but
I'll figure it out
[Laughter]
interestingly bro your levels are [__]
you guys expect me to watch this podcast
can y'all make a watchable product first
wait watch this and I would have done
I've been on Tosh.0 I'm here I've been
around on Glee project you know I I I
get show business I get it but it's you
Ethan it was you nothing I mean yes that
that was the cherry on top
but it all came down to you that was the
dingleberry on the whole I feel like I'm
repeating myself but yes go ahead yeah
there's the crew that's such a big it's
a big setup people it's funny our old
podcast people would come in and say oh
it's so much smaller than I expected I'm
playing you office I'm doing this right
now it's [__] crazy which I actually
much prefer how they get that [__]
rabbit to sit there the whole time
now we got two of them what's he doing
what's interestingly the pit of an auto
club wait this is so [__]
the levels of it it's like weird
yeah dude they're not a top level show
like us
wait wait where is this the right time
stamp baby yeah you can watch right now
I'm just confused okay it's like his
butthole
that's pretty cool which is nicer a
nicer like uh just a minute ago
oh when I said his [__] looks like a
cow vagina no you were saying an avocado
pit looks like his [__] and at this
point in our reaction we had watched
Nick say a bunch of times like he
talking about
when you you went well
again okay but I was flattering his
name's Nick ocado I was right away on
words I don't think he was flattered but
don't you think I think you know that if
okay if you could choose for your
[__] to be look like a cow's vagina
or an avocado pit no this was definitely
you yeah complimenting him or attempting
to compliment him yeah interesting I'm
sure your butthole looks like a fresh uh
piece of nutmeg
yeah with that you know what I'm talking
about or is it what spice is that hold
on yeah thank you
okay I found this dude's Channel and he
has videos from 11 years ago just like
that okay you could probably only listen
to a couple seconds of this because of
copyright but I think it's worth it just
three seconds this 80d [__] A B what are
you doing no he's right we gotta go back
okay this is what I was Dan your
butthole probably looks like a fresh
piece of star anise a nice little piece
of star anus
but NECA caught him on the other hand
has seen some traffic
oh my God stop
oh my God
you'll see he literally says you never
learn stop talking maybe you should
watch it wait what did I say that's
wrong no stop talking about his [__]
it's very simple I was talking about
your ass it doesn't matter it's
inappropriate to talk about anybody's
[__] but seriously is that where
we're drawing the line Dan I can't talk
about your butthole now what we're
talking about I've never seen your
butthole for the record okay that's
great this is just like this is just
like you speculating about yes bro you
speaking about nicocado's body
should stop
he's not he doesn't find it amusing he
finds it offensive
you should watch the clip
I'm not going to
need to look back at uh our boy
here I gotta pull up this cheers
why'd you send this he looks the same 13
days ago no no I want you to just hear
three seconds of this country roads
no no it was that a good time okay okay
uh
uh oh
Lord
I know it's gonna be good but I'm gonna
get claimed I know it's gonna be I just
I just love West Virginia
but I'll tell you as a non-native
English speaker when I was younger I
definitely sang songs like this I didn't
know the lyrics but I just made it sound
American sure and I think that's kind of
what he's doing on an open yeah
foreign
I just want to say first of all I did
not make any new accusations about
Nick's butthole I was simply getting
refreshed yes I said it was like a cow's
vagina I shouldn't have said that wait
hold on I'm not saying it does I'm
taking it back and apologizing the
avocado pit was I might I was attempting
to compliment him but I see that also
about looking like an avocado pit is
also not and then I said oh well you're
laughing you'll probably have a perfect
star anise butthole
right and maybe he does too you know
also he said he's got lots of traffic
you know that was insensitive what I
meant is that
or like you go cow Style
you guys know what I meant okay but it
was really put
and not not to be derogatory right it's
just he has a significant other and they
get me out of this
[Music]
somebody else just watch the video
I can't hear it wait is that their
volume it is their volume that's
terrible what the [__] not wrong about
that part more talk about it but that's
more fun he does it
learn peasants are we following along
okay
he just doesn't get it it's so offensive
you know ice dude I'm not taking this
guy seriously
this guy's telling me I'm offended by
what he said in his body I'm not I'm
sorry but like you all can't tell me
that he's actually [__] offended well
he he does say in this that he does not
mesh only fans with his YouTube content
which I have found that he doesn't
normally uh promote his only fans like
sexual content on YouTube so that's him
he did say that he differentiates it but
um so
okay okay
but show this show this okay this man is
telling me he's offended by what he said
about his body I mean his belly button's
wider than my [__]
so of course his butthole's gonna be
tennis ball sized and that's just
because his butt
[Music]
but do you see what I'm saying I'm not
taking him seriously and and why is this
time yeah okay thank you
I just want to defend myself adequately
foreign
and he was like oh thank God someone's
nice to my wife imagine how you feel if
I was just dissing her over and over and
over you wouldn't want me to be in the
same space with you like everyone I
didn't ever said anything about his
significant other I didn't understand
that analogy I'm talking about him he's
talking about me
you know
that's their fit
it's just not look that big
[Laughter]
gigantic it was only gigantic wait his
crew member just said your butthole is
gigantic they have a small conversation
so guys really you gotta stop blaming me
okay
this butthole is open for debate this
butthole is a matter of public interest
this [__] is in the public discourse
okay and it is open for debate
clearly what takes place in their
podcast proves that
[Music]
people you cannot take him seriously
people here's some comments look they go
even no just picture this saying about a
woman dude show me a woman who takes
their body in in the same way that Nick
does you mean sex workers
do you mean that I think like yeah I
guess if I was talking about a sex
worker's body in the same way and you
literally are doing that he hasn't only
fans he makes a living off of it I know
someone said imagine you said that about
a woman it would you be offended uh show
me someone who's doing parading his body
around like this like making a joke of
his physical thing I I do that too and I
don't care when people make fun of my
looks because I play it up it's a matter
of public discourse just like his giant
[__] gaping [__]
foreign
he doesn't get it he just doesn't get it
it's so offensive you know I said a nice
complement about about it's not the same
if there was a woman who sat and did
shows like this I don't I mean I don't
think it's as be as offensive as you as
you think it would be
about Eli and he was like oh thank God
someone's nice to my wife imagine how
you feel if I was just dissing her over
and over and over you wouldn't want me
to be in the same space with you like
everyone has their fit
it does not look that big
[Laughter]
gigantic it was only gigantic dude
literally he said his [__] is
gigantic that's
put something up and pulled it out real
quick and shot the it doesn't matter
Maybe
carrot a carrot it was one of those big
ones from Costco when we
this is not about what I did in that
moment this about it is everything
matters everything is Up For Debate no
y'all being sensitive stop y'all really
getting mad at me he said it's a
bottle's huge I think that's like more
directly insulting than me saying it
looks like a cow's vagina at least
that's more poetic
I there's imagination are you looking to
me listen I'm I'm just looking out for
you because you're gonna get cooked in
the comments section now so you can
decide whether you give a [__] about
that or not all I'm saying is
he multiple times has said stop talking
about my butthole and you're saying no
so I'm not adding new discourse you're
doing yes you are yes you are what did I
say now you said oh you said several
things today about comparing the cow's
vagina comparison to the avocado things
okay fine fair enough what I'm saying is
you've decided him saying you can't talk
about my [__] you're overruling that
you're saying yes I can no no I agree
I'm gonna stop I'm stopping talking
about his [__] but here I'm watching
a conversation of him talking about his
[__] right now am I allowed to talk
about his [__] is tearing this family
apart but he's like tell me he's tell me
wait can I talk about Nick's [__]
okay we say no you can talk about it
anytime you want you just have to
understand that people are gonna get
upset about it the Beatrix is coming for
you Ethan you gotta you gotta be ready
for that
I actually frankly don't understand why
anyone would be upset of me chiming in
now he's talking about his he said
massive [__] okay and he even smiled
and laughed he's given us the backstory
because they're buds he's cool with him
talking about it he said Ethan
I'm just telling I'm just pointing out
he specifically wants you to talk stop
talking about his [__] and you're
saying he's never asked no I know I I
said yes I'm not I'm not I'm not talking
about his [__]
you're talking about his [__] I
didn't bring it up you're literally
talking non-stop about his [__]
I'm trying if we had a stopwatch damn
big baited
Dan has spent so much time talking about
nicakata's [__] oh my God he could be
a [__] dingleberry on his ass peeps
[Applause]
IE can we get carrots in the chat please
they're already there I've been seeing
them I'm sure they'll be more hold on
listen to this
[Music]
you know what that's fine I'm stopping
you go you do the rest of the segment no
it's listen I like the input
I just genuinely don't understand if
people are actually mad like that's kind
of throwing me off
was one of those big ones from Costco
can we get carrots in the chat please
guys they're going yep more please
there's a lot of them more do you think
this this is about how many carrots you
must have put up there to make it that
way no
no that's not that many
everyone everyone who said a carrot
shame on you
all right sorry about that one couldn't
help myself
this is not about what I did in that
moment this about him
but it's less flattering than not
commenting on his [__]
period
but at the same time at the same time
What not that crazy because that's like
hunger FF coming out here and being like
I don't want to talk about my prologue
the only fans I don't ever blur YouTube
and of ever I don't understand that
point
ever ever and I'm a I love to
self-promote myself and you know you
just I mean he kind of just did talking
about what he put up his ass and stuff
but okay I mean right I mean he because
I was thinking like this is promo
because now by the way some of our fans
are going to want to see what all the
hubbubs about
and I'm just saying dude you're getting
paid right now
people are saying I can't wash it so
uncomfortable dude this is like
as good as it gets this is as good
you are watching the wrong show I'm
saying yeah if this is making you that
uncomfortable this is the wrong show for
you they want to go watch BFFs or some
[__] like that yeah
watch the last podcast on the left yeah
no no sure that's a good one I love it
yeah there it is besides can it get it
much worse at this point
it can okay and I'm trying to bet I know
we don't have a strike but it could get
much worse you're right you're actually
it could always get much worse being
involved yeah
follow my new Twitter real nicocado do
it follow it
followed my Twitter everybody Olivia Dan
Ethan it's called real nicocado I just
made it two weeks ago because the other
one slipped also follow me follow me
wait so is he saying he doesn't post
promo on the Twitter but I don't care
it's still part of his life what am I
supposed to do it's like who you know I
made Moonlight as a [__]
I made Moonlight as like a [__]
mercenary that kills Iraqi villagers but
don't bring it up because I don't talk
about it in my daily life I don't know
Blackwater I'm just trying to think of
something but it doesn't make any sense
of course it's who you are I don't care
where you promote it
you know what I mean
so I love to promote myself I never ever
maybe like once or twice years ago when
I first made it because I was excited
but I was like nope this this is this is
going to be a thing that's separate it's
a it's a it's a different line of work
it has nothing to do with the rest so
saying oh well this person does it so I
should he I should assume he
it's just so just that shows how much
how little they've actually have they
made you regret it at all by talking
about it so much who them have them
bringing up your butthole so much made
you okay hold on this is not like I'm
not having like full seminars on Nick's
[__]
segments
a full segment on Nick's [__] like a
PowerPoint like what's a full segment I
mean how long have we been talking about
it right now
yeah but we're not talking about the
butthole we're having a meta
conversation it's a conversation about
the conversation okay fair enough it's
been 17 minutes
all right posting that photo
no a lot of people liked it
you can laugh and Google oh you want
boys a lot of people a lot of people
liked it I like it I didn't like it I
get excited looking at it a lot of
people liked it it was really nice but
that's my opinion right that's my right
and has nothing again so his logic never
said it wasn't beautiful
again you're putting words in my mouth I
think it was a beautiful [__] bro
I never gave up I think for calling it
saying it looks like a cow's vagina
probably could be construed as an insult
I think right where you live I think
comparing us I mean it definitely
depends on where you live and what your
upbringing if you know what I'm saying
but uh what baby I think comparing it to
killing Iraqis let me make it sound
pretty bad I understand the analogy
though he's Moonlighting yeah yeah no I
got I'm supposed to ignore that you know
what I mean
I couldn't think of anything better I
mean obviously he's not killing yeah
just saying
I did not say disgusting
he they said disgusting right there in
the room with him I never said that as
well if this hunger FF does something
then he should I think that's a meme or
something on there I haven't I don't
know what that is the hunger FF thing
I'm not sure that's got to be like uh
this [__] bro have some respect for
them
I can't find it yeah it's not being I
wasn't too oh they're gonna google it oh
no never ever oh no don't do it work
ever just I gotta see his reaction I'm
improving avocado pit is a step up so
that's true
baby steps then he's doing better
we don't trust trust me we don't I could
have said it looks like a whole avocado
which would be worse because it's bigger
right just in and out no one's reacting
to him Ethan read the room read the room
I don't know I don't get where I am by
reading the room Nick okay and I think
you know a little bit about what I'm
talking about too okay that's that's
probably fair to say thank you
okay
about your podcast I don't know much
about your history these people read the
room they're sitting in silence you
don't get it you don't get it and you're
out you're wanting them to jump on the
back the wagon here you just want a mean
girl group there they get it you don't
I'll do the podcast with you not there
how about that that would be funny okay
okay this is actually a good idea he
says he'll come do the podcast if I'm
not there by the way this man is mad
okay this man is walking around in
public first of all this is lewd conduct
this man should go to [__] jail and
they're mad about what I'm saying like
this is a public [__] Forum I'm sorry
I'm the bad guy for commenting on his
body stop he just posted this
and also he said that this is he doesn't
talk about his only fans not that it's a
good point but what the [__] is this if
not promo
I'm showing up that hotbod
read the grocery store groceries
is that a public one too
real nickel no that's his no I mean is
that a public little scooter that
everyone can use oh [__] you're right
that probably once it's for the public
yeah it may not be I don't know that for
sure I'm not gonna say that it might be
his but yeah the ones at the grocery
stores have a basket for groceries
my five-year-old cruising through the
grocery store with me is gonna look at
this and the vegetable aisle feeding
vegetables hard enough as it is bro I
don't need this association with
broccoli right right right well that's
fair read the groceries so back the [__]
off me
thank you
some of y'all really too too much for me
[Music]
I mean dude his ass crack is out that's
crack
a lot more than that though
okay I think I got a little bit of a
High Ground on that one
okay
thank you you can watch in a monitor in
the car can I come oh yeah yeah so we
were saying so I was wondering either we
can have fake Ethan or Ela have an
earpiece and I'll feed them what I want
them to say and they can conduct the
interview you can't say that why are you
saying that on the show right well it's
obvious that's it no because now he's
going to react to this clip and then he
won't do it because you just gave away
coming anyway the man can't fly
it's got to pay for like three C's it's
just not economical
foreign
[Music]
stop it he's this he likes being big
that's his whole thing
actually that's not even a joke he said
he needs two seeds didn't he like oh
no yes he did he did say that he did
dance first class stop making me look
bad he literally said he needs two seats
when we bought him his [__] seats
God damn it
he said first class because
we bought him one seat no he said if
your coach if it's coach that's why he
did his first first class because
they're bigger seats
okay Dan
don't push
no that's not about you
maybe not even that huh probably like a
raisin what an ass I said his ass who
looks like a raisin
that's even smaller than star anus I
think that was definitely an Olive
Branch from yeah from you I don't know
if he liked it but I think that it was
an attempt his butthole looks like an
Olive Pit
flavors now that's a compliment
flavors
yeah
um although the one who's in the I mean
it's subjective
what are you into for him to keep on
bringing this up and he just he just
wants to think of that image more so he
has not left his his mind neither is it
left mine
do you know OLED TVs you know how they
get a burn and if you leave an image too
long on it and it just stays there
permanently well if you're really
bothered by it when I close you when it
brings about your [__] okay but if
you really didn't like it I'm not
bothered by it don't bring it up you
would try to forget but I respect the
hustle bro that's it I'm not bothered by
it
it's awesome
it's different all different flavors for
everybody
imagine it no every time I close my eyes
I see it
and maybe maybe he's scarred for life I
don't know but get something else to
talk about
gosh I can't be the first person that
has X extra wide I don't know go ahead
he's got a nice little B hole that looks
like a just stops
I was trying to be nice you're trying to
be nice I think I was trying to be flat
I'm pretty good I was trying to get a
nice little B hole I think he likes it I
mean there's really no uh explanation
I've seen uh other people's stuff that I
don't like I don't want to have a
discussion about it I just want to be
like all right sure he is like hyper
obsessed with it he's he really seems to
like it you guys he really seems to be
into it he really does I mean I I think
it's nice a lot of other people three
thousand people it's awesome I think
he's one of those people
he went on to my patreon yes dude I
never said I'm not you certainly are one
of the people interested in enough to
purchase it well okay so let's think
about this like from a business
perspective his product in this case he
literally sold this image his product is
this picture of his [__] now that
picture is meant to be consumed public
domain it's right and so he's selling
this picture of his [__] and then
he's telling me don't talk about my
[__] I think it's more he's saying
don't talk about me and my [__] if
I'm coming to Los Angeles and I'm gonna
be hanging out in the studio
right by the way people say Ethan I
don't I understand your point but he's
uncomfortable so please don't die on
this hill but here's what I think he's
not he's not uncomfortable and I don't
know I don't think he cares at all
yeah it's hard to say
I mean he I don't know he's saying it is
he is so
you know I guess we gotta respect it but
also he's known for going back and forth
and doing these kind of things so it's
hard to say
flavors
[Laughter]
did he
yes he did I mean it's like that's like
putting out an album as a band being
like don't talk about my album
here's my best here's the best work I've
ever made in my career don't talk about
it
here's Sergeant Pepper beetles put out
Sergeant Pepper lonely heartband don't
talk about Sergeant Pepper
it's just my Magnus opum I open Opus
open
yeah just career defining moment don't
talk about it
Magnum opum
Magnum opalumpa
I don't know you guys
weight loss updates in the nude
it was not it was not sexual or anything
it was just me it was just like Hospital
uh medical type of posing just with your
[__] out straight yeah but I was soft I
wasn't touching it promoing by the way
not that I care either way but very you
know he's getting subs from this like
watching a medical video of like here's
person's weight you know what they're
going to do uh plastic surgery they kind
of like carve lines on their body just
standing there in the nude just natural
and open
there's no sexual about it at all but he
he was there he was watching he was
looking at it yeah I'm confused what do
you think he was talking about yeah we
pretty much watched the the two time
stamps we thought were good second one
being that
you guys should do the podcast with you
in the car that'd be awesome I'd love to
do that I like the idea of you getting
video privileges when when you're doing
well you get to call in VC that's funny
I like that
so this is it but I don't know every
time I talk about Nick everyone gets so
sensitive about it
don't stick over here
you know what I mean
but yeah I will die on this [__] Hill
you all say I will definitely die and
you can bury me in his [__] when I'm
[__] dead on this hill it's big
enough
yes speaking of Barry maybe we should
move on
maybe we should talk about I'm gonna
bury that old [__] man how about we
talk about that [__] that [__] guy
yeah I see you in chat
[__] isn't he isn't he like 60. yeah
he's [__] the oldest [__] dirt
no I'm not someone older than Jay Leno
I'm gonna rock him like
oh
thanks for the distraction bro we needed
that
I'm trying out here
Jay Leno
this is opium
that's how I feel every time I talk
about Nick a color
all right thank you Nick nice to hear
from you it's all love I genuinely mean
that and I I just want to say from the
heart I don't think it's gross I don't
think you're gross I respect the hustle
your true entrepreneur you're a true
player at heart and um
and like you said a lot of people
enjoyed that picture I'm one of them so
like obviously you know you do you bro
and um I'm I do apologize if I offended
you with any of my jokes it's just kind
of it's just you know I'm a dick I'm an
[__] and I make bad jokes like that
and that's just you know what I mean but
sometimes I go too far and um
and uh I apologize if I've offended uh
your if I've apologized if I've offended
this man here
who is just the most respectable
dignified member of society explosion
McCoy in the veggie section that was
tweeted out recently by the way to just
uh if we can Jan 11th he's really a
stand-up Citizen and uh and we we love
that about you so I owe you the respect
you deserve and I truly do apologize for
those of you guys who found the Vlog to
be offensive I'm sorry you did no you
didn't find it to be offensive I'm sorry
that's not what I said you know I do
kind of feel like that Jay Leno edit
because I'm not driving I'm just
passenger I'm just going all over the
place I have no control rocked around
yeah
yeah no but we're friends
I do feel like we're friends like I have
no I mean I don't know I hope so I hope
we are but okay that's that so thank you
peace and love peace and love to Nick
ocado and his hosts
[Music]
listen what can I say what can I say
please
I gotta find a longer version It's gotta
be out there
so
um oh boy thank you to uh Nick ocado who
I do love unironically big thing
moving on to something
I guess
kind of a hard segue but it is what it
is Adult Swim so Adult Swim posted this
that was quite a segment
I feel like this made [__] go crazy with
this Justin Roiland story
because before it was kind of under the
radar a bit but now when this happened I
saw everybody talking about it I don't
think the um
the the text messaging uh young women
aspect of this is has really uh that
news has spread that much because in
when they made this announcement I went
and looked at uh you know discussion
threads on Twitter and Reddit and stuff
and everyone's just talking about the
charges I barely see anybody talking
about yeah the charges is honestly not
not even like the issue right now right
because he look
he's going to go through the legal
system with that one right
but this [__] is like [__] receipts
yeah like that one I don't know which
one it was but he this girl goes I'm 16
and then he proceeds to flirt with her
he goes I'm 16 and he goes cool so
anyway back to our conversation it's
crazy dude
yeah and I mean I this is purely
speculation but I have to imagine that
the conversation at Adult Swim because
obviously this is a [__] huge deal is
there is their biggest show by Massive
property by far he's the Creator he
voices the two main characters it's not
easy and like 80 of all the characters
on the show right so it's not easy for
them to turn their back on that so when
the news about the Chargers came out I'm
sure there were a lot of back and forth
conversations going on behind the scenes
of like what do we do maybe we should
suspend him for a while or whatever
but
shortly after the text message stuff
started coming out is where we see them
drop him and I have to imagine that that
was uh
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back there where they were like
it was because I'll let this guy go when
you're at trial you have plausible
deniability you can say we're gonna let
this run its course right and see what
happens but then when all these receipts
start dropping uh you really can't deny
what you see right in front of your face
like this one I mean there's a whole
bunch of them but like this one with the
16 year old girl
trying to find
it's just wild dude it's just like why
oh this is the jailbait one right but
wait I think it's cut out where she says
she's 16. doesn't have the full combo
yeah this is not complete
but yeah she said she's 60 and they
proceeds to call her jailbait like 20
times
so yeah they said adult swims and its
association with Justin royland
Rick and Morty will continue
the talented and dedicated crew are hard
at work on season seven yeah I mean I
get why they're continuing it I think
it's a fine decision obviously like a
huge operation there
but
we'll see we'll see you know I don't
think I I personally don't think they
need to shut down the whole show because
of this
but it's a matter of if they continue
can do it or not
right
I mean they gotta try from their
perspective like they're they're in so
deep with like backing the show that I
feel like pulling the plug all together
is just not an option for them dude it's
got to be like 70 of their whole Revenue
yeah
um somebody donated ten dollars and said
Zach I sent you the link on Instagram
for the full Chestnut
oh sweet okay Yumi Rose or yummy Rose
thank you very much so thank you for oh
we got the full version uh somebody
donated 10 bucks and said they sent it
to Zach holy [__] dude
that's a huge thank you yummy rose that
is so awesome
that country song is so good though
I wish I could listen to it well let's
let's see if it gets claimed and then
I'll see if I can play it or not
oh true yeah
a little bad
[Music]
oh it ends
weird okay no it's getting charged now
[Music]
um
yeah it's sad man I just don't know why
people can't just behave like holy [__]
and the amount of stuff that's out there
just surprised me like dude you knew
this was gonna happen like come on
foreign
there it is people thinking with their
dicks
you know what I mean I sure do
all right let's talk about something
else so there's that
we gotta talk about EB's fight yeah
that's what I want to talk about by the
way lean are you here
were you able to contact the vet
so you said that doctor will email us
when she gets it and it'll it will
likely be tomorrow okay okay okay thank
you
uh congratulations a b his opponent has
been announced and I've been wanting you
guys to know this is kind of a crazy
matchup dude it's a b verse dad
maybe I gotta ask you like seriously
what the [__] dude okay is this the same
photo or no it's not this why did you
think that listen let me let me look
tougher listen I've never even seen this
photo in my life I've never seen it
until the poster was out
what but you're right I so I was like
trying to figure it out but the band on
my hand is what I was wearing right
before the Creator Clash so I think they
took pictures of us at some point
and they're like we're gonna get this
guy in like a year against him yeah I
know everyone says my hands look
photoshopped
um and I and you know I don't like it
but I don't hate it as much as the last
one I kind of find it funny because how
scary dad looks and like I look like a
little [__] uh oh baby they're setting
up a little like um what's it called in
pro wrestling it's like the face and the
heel or like the two like the the good
guy and the bad guy so what you're yeah
maybe it's the heel no he's the face
he's the face that's why he's like he's
like the soft pretty boy and then you
got the scary uh dad coming to kick his
ass
[__] AB this picture I don't know man
why didn't you showed me the picture you
sent them before maybe right no I yeah
cam Kim actually made an edit of the
last year's one and he took me out of
the living room but I guess I didn't
submit it in time
because this is what we got you're mean
mugging in that at least they're just
they're just yeah see this one you look
kind of tough this is the one from last
year this one's kind of too nice of a
guy
no it's it's the big eyes they're not
intimidating there's nothing I can do
yeah [__] no you look more intimidating
in this one
this one is just not not great bro I
look like an upset child for the
intimidation factor it's not happening
you got sent home without dessert you
got sent to your room they made you wear
a race a way a wristband when you're at
boxing uh when we're it's a VIP so we
can get in the back and stuff I think
this is before like the VIP mixer and
everything we had to weigh in in the
press conference oh okay yeah
yes so I'll be honest though I think I
actually think you're gonna win
because Dad is old as [__] and
he fought Matt Watson he beat him in
like 12 seconds we don't get we didn't
get an adequate read on his boxing
abilities but I have seen videos of dad
boxing not impressed
looks bad Dude Looks rough
yeah yeah I don't I don't want to say
too much but I gotta say last time like
Brett put up his photo I think it was
right when we got to Vegas we all went
on that vacation and it like killed the
first day for me because the whole
internet was telling me I'm gonna die
and I was like terrified already I was
like holy [__] Brett looked huge but now
like I don't the whole internet
something I'm gonna die again but I'm
not I'm not worried this time good yeah
yeah you're ready for better or worse I
mean everyone commenting really like
listen dad is a scary dude you know he
has crazy stamina but at the same time
uh to say I'm dead you guys don't even
like you you haven't even seen a box I
know because I haven't seen a box you
know what I mean we'll pull up a video
of him boxing let's let's analyze it
but you know the Matt Watson fight
because that's the only like actual no
there's videos him training oh doing
like punching the bag
somebody said uh the buck tooth once
said these fighters from Mike Tyson's
punch out did not age well that's
exactly you look like the first opponent
and punch out JB
and you're probably aware of this second
or third what you're probably aware of
this but Dad is in the chat and he's
talking a lot of [__] right now so he is
oh yeah sorry sorry Dad I don't pay
everywhere
which one is he where is he oh he's in
chat yeah I've been seeing his messages
like AB just said I'm not gonna worry
and I see that he just replied worry
thank you
um well Dad you can keep [__] farting
in the wind AKA leaving little chats for
you but at the end of the day you should
be training right now not in our chat
because you're old as [__] oh
a nice fan was just yeah a fan was just
nice enough to provide me with a much
meaner looking a b photo
thank you Chris thank you I can't even
tell if it's edited anymore it's at you
think my eye looks like [__] I don't
know I don't like the only picture of
you ah
I appreciate that Chris Shout Out
cheers
the full version please two minutes and
20 seconds oh we are blessed today oh we
gotta check if it's copyrighted though
because I know that little clip didn't
yeah I will uh I'll check it yeah
thank you to Jennifer she asked uh will
I ever make music again
Because You Loved my song [__] monster
thank you so much you know it's hard to
it's hard to
put so much into this show and also have
time to do anything else
I like to do music and stuff it's fun
but I mean it's not it's not like my
life you know what I mean I'd love to
write a song with you
'll be very fun
uh Aaron ants uh gifted 50 subs thank
you so much I know I know it's crazy
bruh yeah so um I oh itubs put out a
video anyone's ego let's see yeah this
announcement video
foreign
[Music]
that's what it looked like if I time
stamped it when I was in it would be
when I knocked down Brett but no you
should go to the beginning that was a
mistake
I want to know how I got this uh
physique that I have right now
at that time I was definitely like a
smaller weight we were planning on
having a different fight a different
opponent I was trying to pick a safe
fight for sure my coach Michael Briggs
he's fantastic given me a lot of insight
and help because I need to check up on
these guys I've been sparring with them
it's scary there's a lot of things to to
this boxer
little weirdo bro
once we realize that it's possible and
that there's like an audience for it
putting all these guys together and
saying that they're training and then
it's going to be it's kind of long it's
like seven minutes
is there a specific moment I should
watch is it but there was this moment
where you walked in here let me click
that again
I if I if I had to pick a moment I mean
anyone's ego check it out
you do look good there yeah I'll give
you I'll give you a time stamp here you
look good dude your beard is long I like
that look tough thank you
this is a good time all right here's the
other time stamp
it was a fight I was waiting for boys
hondar versus a bam did that hurt or you
didn't even feel it no at that point I
was literally walking straight into them
look at the Alfredo cam
Africa's got his own little reaction
what was that Ian that edited
versus a b
doesn't seem like it's gonna happen
yes dude
if you look in the background like if
you go back a frame you see Lena jump up
right behind I think there was a push on
the subreddit about that Lena oh yeah
here you are Lena right here
uh it's under your
yeah there you go let me go back you can
see it yeah that's me oh you haven't
seen this that's all so cute here let me
go back just a touch versus a
bunch it doesn't seems like it's gonna
happen oh okay now I'm just ready
okay she's like down here somewhere
oh [__] yeah
the boxing match between a father and a
son and a father beats the [__] out oh
[__] yeah okay are you worried about
your pituitary gland Amy
um
no I don't know I get a million comments
about every second I know Joe Rogan
seems to think you could be depressed
forever
yeah as a result of this
it turns out the pituitary glands in
like the center of your head so that
seems like I'm not sure how you would
damage that around like 4 15 is the
lineup of the all the fighters I'll go
there emo jalapeno thank you so much for
the five gifted what what's the time
stamp 415
I would sure yeah yeah sure
no uh well let's see this year's
Fighters a B versus Dad wait okay wait
whose voice is that I reckon that's that
Jack's uh sorry not just oh yeah yeah
okay jacksepticeye yeah that's cool can
we hear that again this is my one and
done you know what I mean like welcome
back AB oh wow it is I didn't realize
that yeah no I I actually met him and I
was talking with him for a while and I
was like oh [__] is that jacksepticeye
because that's not his real name his
real name's not Jack it's John or
something Sean what's his real name oh
Sean Sean yeah and I met him I had no
idea that was him Irishman named Sean
Sean I think it works John no I was
being sarcastic but you know um oh is
that an Irish name
oh [__] okay I think like half the
island his name Sean especially how he
spells it too
I would say though uh you know of all
the match-ups this one's pretty
interesting because I was very excited
to see Dad fight again because I wanted
to see him fight and this is gonna be a
juicy match I gotta say Abe it's going
to be exciting to see this one go down
yeah it's gonna be the first fight of
the night too I believe
so you you've got to just Outlast Matt
Watson bro Matt's going to be there I
was actually talking to Matt yesterday
you should have him in your corner and
do some kind of goof with it oh we have
Joe Rogan some Joe Rogan look alike
crying in your corner stop the fight
I said if I want Matt to come down like
a like a guardian angel you're the cool
you're the cool stepdad who uh who is uh
standing up he got your stepson's uh
bully father
all right let's see the other Fighters
foreign
and I think these British people should
be stopped
fits versus I did a thing
Alana Pierce versus Mika I wasn't
surprised that surprised me yeah great
question you should do this for a living
wording myself look at this lady I
shouldn't even be able to talk about
this it's gonna be a wild fight these
two
smash a human centipede Super Trooper is
she not
Maybe not maybe yeah she is she's like a
fan of the show yeah she is Lana yeah I
didn't know that I mean I don't know how
much she watches the show
I believe she is well then we're Team I
mean I I like her I'm friendly with her
but um
I don't know how much you watching but
definitely we're we're rooting for
for her
pooper Troopers always get precedent
crank gameplays versus leonhardt
oh yeah I went on like a whole hour long
time yeah all right sorry
he's family dude what do you think about
this a former opponent turned bestie or
cousin yeah I don't I don't know I don't
know every time I leave like me and
Brett have been talking more recently uh
we hung out recently but then like last
night Miss mom like messaged me and said
uh and shall I'll be their front row
cheering you on this is gonna be the
night that your cousin avenges you
something along those lines oh that's
actually interesting yeah so but didn't
myth when the chess boxing tournament so
he's got some skill oh no he's yeah I
know he was doing great yeah
that'll be interesting xqc is not
sliding it's visualization okay before
you work on yourself you have to have a
picture
oh yeah like I know obviously we saw
hunters in great shape for his age but
he's 39 he's almost 40 and myth 23. that
seems rough yeah I mean initially wow
that's a huge yeah that's not initially
they were thinking of pairing me with
myth and then uh I didn't want to do
that because you know one were related
sure but also like to be honest a lot of
people are saying it's not fair I should
have been paired with myth I'd much
rather be paired with Dad if I'm being
honest like myth is Young dude he's a
beast yeah wait look at look at him
throwing shots here
yeah he looks good for yeah I mean brand
new to it too so but xqc is fighting
soda popping Is that real versus Sonos
300 confirm on this right yeah okay I
was like hell no that's not I'm not
going so it's not going in yeah I'm not
[__] going
okay
moving on Marisha Ray versus Haley Sharp
so Haley's a Super Trooper
and we support her through thick and
thin
critical role I was I didn't I'm I'm
familiar with the girl on the left too
wait who is she she does she's part of
that group it's critical role are you
familiar with them it's like a big I
want to say YouTube channel maybe it's a
twitch Channel they play like uh
Dungeons and Dragons like as like a
group on camera okay well I hope you
don't like her too much because yodeling
Haley is a Super Trooper I'm not I'm not
like a huge fan but I'm familiar with
who she is
no yeah
we need that right better
Haley trying to jab in what the [__] is
this
yeah Haley's a seasoned fighter Jarvis
Johnson versus Marissa at the uh chess
boxing match she's very sweet but we do
love Haley so another match is gonna be
hard to cheer for someone
Chris Reagan versus Froggy Fresh
I know Chris he's a nice guy
Froggy Fresh is gonna [__] turn his
face into minced shepherd's pie dude
he's jacked up my time has come
just got done
yeah yeah he's a beast bro he's been
exercising for a while he's like jacked
his [__] Sabrina versus Jayla Ray
Harley morinstein versus John Morris no
we don't say the m word anymore the
n-word it's this one now very well what
what oh that I did not get that maybe he
changed his boxing numbers he used to go
by the wrestling name of uh John
Morrison
what's wrong with that I don't know oh
maybe that if that was a um uh yeah WWE
might own it yeah might not legally be
allowed to compete under that name got
it Harley morningstein versus Johnny
Elite
[Applause]
all right
oh he's six feet versus Harley six seven
okay wow that's what I forgot about a
little bit of a tight differential there
he's a professional uh athlete though
yeah that'll be interesting so
and finally for the main event idubbbz
versus Alex Wassabi
I think Ian's gonna take covering this
exciting lineup we have sfand amaranth
jacksepticeye ooh that's me
Markiplier chills Tony Jeffries voice
critical Wade plemons and akinola
verisimo now that's gonna be a show
I'm looking forward to it it's already
next month or no two months
Corp is that the real corpse husband
that is not oh [__] I was about to be
like hit it
but thank you
we honor you every day here Corps we
appreciate the five bucks anyways
yeah thank you to uh
dad is direct from his gig and bum
fights
does Mark
that's hilarious
yeah thank you uh corb's husband fake
corpse husband
so I don't know it's it's going to be
April 15th
oh so it's a few months pretty close to
4 20.
five days from 4 20 I'm just saying
right bro y'all can just wait five more
days
am I right you know what I mean you guys
know what I'm talking about
it's [__] nice out
because
I'm so high right now guys
I smoke two giants in the afternoon
we're playing weed right now
all right thank you let's not get lost
out I got less in the 420 hole album of
reactions oh no maybe
it's not looking good in the reaction
world is it no I could have added a lot
more this took me two seconds he's dead
y'all five thousand Reddit
that's our subreddit by the way not dead
subreddit that is our fans yeah nobody's
in Dad's subreddit you're watching yeah
[Music]
the only person in Dad's subreddit is
Dad
thanks Zach wasn't that funny you were
generous
I appreciate it
um they might need to break out this
thumbnail again
nah you're gonna be good dude
these are my predictions from the UFC
event last weekend as this guy's an
analyst yeah okay
it should be plus 1200 he's just saying
I I think you said like I had a one and
oh yeah one in ten chance at winning
yeah wait how does he determine that
though he pulled it right out of his
[__] he's lying through his teeth he
doesn't have any data he's got like two
fights each you have two fights
that's [__] you're gonna [__]
destroy him I actually believe that this
time well yeah also I don't know what
kind of analyst uses like 30 seconds of
footage to make his analysis
nine watch he's gonna get it perfectly
it's gonna be like can you get this spot
on scene for scene Philip DeFranco even
coming out to talk [__]
are you allergic to fighting non-scary
opponents
you're listen you're a warrior
you know that's it you're a war you're a
fighter at heart like uh Logan Paul
that's what he said
when he got caught scamming people
not but did someone Photoshop this how
did he manage to look less intimidating
than last year
yeah I know if you go down if you scroll
down you can see it I feel that brother
and Dad's is really good by the way his
his abs look crazy he looks scary
he could be I think 20 pounds heavier
this year too so
wait he has to put on 20 pounds no we're
the same weight right now we're both
that weight but um when he fought Matt I
think he had to be at 150 pounds and
we're at 175 right now so he can put on
muscle I think he already did because
he's lean as [__] that guy doesn't put
on fat
wow
wow wow maybe he looks lost chest as I
am this is AB after the show yeah I love
that sorry bud oh no abia's gonna die
yeah you know what though I feel I'm
feeling it this year dude everyone loves
a good Underdog Story Amy's gonna
[__] murder him thank you thank you
it's it's better than expectations are
that you're gonna lose so there's no
pressure on you right yeah and and you
know worse comes to worse if if I do
become a meme I'm glad that uh I could
alleviate Matt from all that pressure
you know that he went you're not there's
no shot you lose about it no I'll join
him in meme Heaven if you know worse
comes to worse or a loser they're nah
you're gonna look good he's probably
gonna come at you fast though like he
did that because he's trying to he
thinks he honestly from that fight I
think is completely deluded into
thinking he can knock anyone out real
fast and he that's not the case with you
is it a b and those hands are going to
be he's definitely not those hands I
promise you that
I think Dad is in for the Battle of a
lifetime I don't think he knows what
he's getting himself into
bro do you know who lucky boy is that's
his coach
[__] killed someone in the ring
[__] you Dad
and he's he goes you get in the ring you
know the risks that's the man coaching a
b yep
literally he said that basically no he
has said that yeah yeah no one of my
first days or first weeks in the gym
actually I don't know if I should say
this legally but someone got [__] up
I'll say that they left on a stretcher
did that shake you at all
the Wally's like see that's what's gonna
happen that's what's gonna happen to you
bro Jesus he's awesome he's awesome yeah
he's great I found this actually this
old clip of me sparring from like early
last year it's just a second clip but I
found it funny I get punched straight
into Adam's apple
here I sent it right here if you want to
pull it up
yeah let's see how can I open this
that looked really painful do they go
back you see that again
let's go talk it up that's it suck it up
did that hurt like a [__] uh yeah it's
just anytime you get hit somewhere that
you're having before like your first
like body good body shot just you're in
shock the neck though the neck yeah the
Adam's apple is weird because I thought
I like died
somebody said
Cam said and I'm not sure how to take
this but
hi Ethan I'm a Goldsmith who specializes
in Memorial jewelry I understand how
hard it is when a pet is not doing well
I recently lost my pup I can find more
info but we can use his paw
nose print and Ashes
wishing the best for Shredder
yeah
he's alive man
for a reason yeah
no I I I'll be honest with you I when I
thought Shredder was going to die for
sure like he's he's doing really good
now but I was thinking what to do with
his body that was horrible but yeah yeah
that didn't come no it's not as weird as
it seems when you were streaming
yesterday in your search history people
saw that you were looking up jewelry for
dead pets yeah so
without that without that context uh
okay yeah that makes sense uh it seems
pretty uh wild but uh
um quite a few things you really gotta
clear your history
I did after that anything else
embarrassing no not this time no and
that's not embarrassing I thought it was
oh that's sweet I mean it's sad yeah
I thought when you were reading that he
was going to say you want me to put a b
and some jewelry I'll put you in a
necklace bro we'll never forget you put
me in a spinner necklace like a big ass
Channel
um turn your ass into a gold fidget
spinner
so you can always be with me
I'll be like Lena here's his remains
it's a gold fidget spinner so he can
always be in your pocket
no because I I don't know it's too it's
so sad you guys I don't want nobody
wants to hear about that it's just sad
man
speaking but I'm not thinking about that
anymore I'm just trying to stay hopeful
and uh he's good now so not thinking
about anything like that right now but
thank you for the suggestion
speaking of uh leaking you almost leaked
the fight early
on the show the other day oh yeah here
it is I couldn't help it dude no leaking
I was talking with uh uh Anthony he's an
Adder my life is a tragedy I'm fighting
for my dead girlfriend I was like talk
about that I don't want to [__] I don't
[__] yeah you don't want to you don't
want a dead girlfriend punch no no
nobody wants a dead girlfriend punched
to the face no but I would pity anyone
who gets in the ring with him dude that
would be a [__] disaster I was just
staring right at you yeah when I
rewatched it Dan switched away from I
switched away intentionally because I
saw what you were doing and uh didn't
want to give away the game entirely well
yeah a lot of people immediately people
still picked up on it but you were
literally doing this I know I know I
just I couldn't help it I was just
trying to be funny I'm doing a little
joke
yeah but anyway no I like Matt Watson
he's just a giant [__] dude yeah he
didn't prep for this he didn't practice
at all yeah so just doing a little stick
but I think I think you're gonna do
great actually thank you after you guys
can already get tickets the
craterclash.com we're gonna do a viewing
party like last time that was super fun
nice
um actually looking forward to that one
should be a blast
are we probably been going about three
hours right
almost on the dot by my estimation yeah
good estimate three hours and 45 seconds
when you said that so yes so
um basically
I am going to try to get out of here at
a normal time so I can go be with my
family
you know what I mean I do I do know what
you mean let's listen to this whole song
at least once
[Music]
I'm gonna scroll through these fashion
picks as we listen what if we get
claimed at the end of the show oh wait
wait did we do we yeah [__] I forgot
we're supposed to copy chicken I was
gonna do it after the show we gotta he
has a whole Channel worth of gold we
could check yeah it's uploaded it takes
like how long does it take like a
quarter of a second
you know what I mean where's the link
oh yeah only Zach
did you guys see this Doja cat look it's
[__] nuts dude
hi
yeah I mean so I like The Vibes I like
how all out she goes she kind of reminds
me of me
yeah I love that for her I'm just like
you for real yeah she's I was reading
about it and it's supposed to be like
fashion for Fashion's sake like
the the like feminism
um or like
being feminine is thrown out the door
and now it's just fashion for Fashion's
sake as opposed to
um fashion norms for for women I just
think it looks cool
it's like all decorative and different
textures it's like crystals little red
crystals there's a video of it being
done but listen Joe the catch the vibe
she shaved her head her eyebrows I've
done that
I uh also it's true like to go I mean I
I don't know I'm Doja cat okay don't
analyze it too deeply
foreign
oh here we go damn she got that
Hellraiser vibes
yeah it's got freaky
I wonder it's a little bit freaky dude
the dedication is incredible
that was not easy to put together
what's the reaction are people thinking
it's cool yeah yeah people really like
it okay yeah um Charlotte Tilbury did
her makeup super famous makeup artist
okay it's a sick look okay cool good for
her love that
wait
okay just Jenna she's she's having a
moment right now I see her everywhere
Jenna Ortega just from that one movie uh
show Wednesday Wednesday
she had a big moment there she was also
in uh a scream and a few of those like 8
24 films
oh she was
[Music]
um this one is kind of interesting
isn't it
he's got that unbuttoned look that's
fresh
just like about to take a piss Vibes Pat
McGrath was the makeup artist
um
okay
awesome
that looks like Paulie Shore is that
polyshore definitely
Usher chestnuts roasting on an open fire
has been copyright claimed no oh
I'll like have to pitch it or something
we'll find a way yeah wait
is that isn't it like that's got to be
like public domain
it's an old it's an old-timey tune but
um you know what I mean like chestnuts
open but even if the
um
even if your song is public domain the
uh
performance you know could still be
copyrighted and specific version of it
well I'm assuming the instrumental
Underneath Him
this is me and Doja cat at the at the
the Vogue fashion
opening
we're just like that we're just gonna go
like that besties and I'm seeing who who
exactly claimed it I would guess
sing to piano sing Two Piano exactly so
it it's the karaoke version that he's
singing over okay okay
all right
just not slurping over open fire
we're gonna have to pitch it because
there's no way we cannot use that this
is kind of
wild love that though
oh what hey is that not Liza koshy
Doja Captain today that's Doja cat
what
are her eyebrows why does that look like
it's photoshopped though is that really
on her face those are eyelashes those
are like fake lashes
and did she do she did two different
looks
well these are different days different
shows
okay slaying once again Unstoppable Doja
cat my best friend
all right I guess that's it then we've
got no chestnuts over open fire such a
bomber
well then just hit me with the short
Loop
okay give me one second you know so I
can I can send this off into a yeah yeah
Liza koshy beautiful I thought it looked
just like her
okay just not slurping yes yes yes yes
now it's slurping over open flower girls
it hits so hard
it just makes winter so comforting it's
methyl I agree
[Music]
yo are those chestnuts in the chat
they have chestnuts what are these
emojis coming from I've never seen that
emoji before who is making chestnuts
[__] Chestnut Emoji let's get some
chestnuts in the chat people yeah oh can
I just say something real quick uh I was
talking to my coach yesterday and lucky
boy said that uh ismp come back on the
show he said yeah he'd love to because
the H3 audience is the nicest group of
people ever he said all of his photos he
gets comments family all the time you
know what's funny our audience is the
nicest or the worst depending on who you
are but you know what they're passionate
and I love that that's what it really is
foreign
just don't mention Andrew Taylor he'll
be good right
that only takes one comment and they'll
turn on him fast
all right guys
um we'll be here tomorrow morning
yes sir
left over for uh leftovers and we got
all kinds of good content and then we'll
be here on Friday with Rebecca Black
that I'm excited about
just not slurping oh more doji cat looks
yeah those are from this week oh oh
damn
oh she hit us with the um
what's that one guy who dressed like
this
didn't it oh yes yeah he hit us with
that CeeLo
Doja cat's so cool do you guys agree
yeah oh yeah she's funny as hell too
love that
all right keep slaying Queen
all right see you guys tomorrow morning
thanks for watching y'all
yes yes yes
[Music]